Hallo und herzlich Willkommen zu Forschergeist, dem Podcast des Stifterverbands für die deutsche Wissenschaft. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und begrüße alle zur 22. Ausgabe unserer Gesprächsreihe rund um Forschung und Bildung. Und heute steht die Bildung im Vordergrund. Wir möchten ein wenig blicken auf die Entwicklung der Lehre als solcher, die ja neben der Forschung einfach ein wichtiges Standbein ist der gesamten Wissenschaftswelt. Und ganz konkret wollen wir nochmal einen weiteren Blick wagen auf die Aspekte der Digitalisierung und die konkreten Auswirkungen davon. Und dazu bin ich heute an die Philips-Universität in Marburg gefahren und begrüße meinen Gesprächspartner, nämlich Jürgen Hanke, schönen guten Tag.
Guten Tag, hallo.
Herr Hanke, Sie sind hier Professor für Anglistik?
Mit Schwerpunkt Linguistik.
Mit Schwerpunkt Linguistik, und das sind Sie wahrscheinlich auch schon eine ganze Weile, ich weiß gar nicht?
Ja seit etwas mehr als 20 Jahren.
Seit 20 Jahren, sehr treue Seele. Was hat Sie in die Lehre und vor allem sagen wir mal überhaupt in die Wissenschaft und das Anglistikthema geführt?
Ich wollte immer schon Lehrer werden. Ich habe ein Lehramtstudium gemacht, das erste Staatsexamen. Wollte auch eigentlich in den Schuldienst und dann kam es wie bei vielen anders, man bekam eine Stelle angeboten und befand sich plötzlich in der akademischen Lehre wieder. Und dann ging das seinen Gang, Promotion, Auslandsaufenthalt, andere Universität, Habilitation und irgendwann war man soweit, dass man eine Professorenstelle übernehmen konnte.
Und das Thema Anglistik selber, inwiefern war das so Ihr Ziel?
Ich habe Englisch studiert, übrigens auch Sport und im Nebenfach noch Philosophie. Aber Englisch hat mich immer schon fasziniert und die Linguistik, also der Teil des Anglistikstudiums, der sich mit der Sprache, mit der englischen Sprache, nicht so sehr mit der Literatur, sondern mit der Sprache Grammatik, Syntax, Semantik, Phonetik befasst, der hat mich eigentlich immer interessiert, weil ich auch mehr so immer in die Naturwissenschaften tendiert habe. Und die Linguistik ist, und das sage ich immer so, vielleicht die naturwissenschaftlichste Geisteswissenschaft. Und deswegen verbinden wir diese beiden Komponenten. Geisteswissenschaft auf der einen, naturwissenschaftliche Methoden auf der anderen. Das hat mich immer gereizt. Und Mitte der 80er Jahre kam dann natürlich die Entwicklung im Bereich der Computer hinzu, und ich hatte frühzeitig eigentlich die Idee, dieses Potenzial des Computers für die Lehre, natürlich auch für die Forschung zu nutzen.
Linguistik spielt ja auch in der Computerwissenschaft eine sehr große Rolle. So Personen wie Noam Chomsky etc. am MIT haben da ja bahnbrechendes konzeptionell geleistet in dem Bereich und auch so dieser Sprung von Linguistik zu Programmiersprachen hat glaube ich schon immer für so eine interessante Brücke gesorgt in dem Bereich oder?
Ja das war bei mir genauso. Meine Promotion war noch zu einem theoretisch linguistischen Thema. Die Habilitation zu einem computerlinguistischen Thema. Also sehr früh kam ich in den 80er Jahren auch in die Programmierung mit hinein, hatte Interesse daran, habe mir das selbst auch durch Besuch von Informatikveranstaltungen bei anderen Kollegen beigebracht und war dann sehr fasziniert davon, wie man mit dem Computer linguistische Probleme auch lösen und bearbeiten kann, bis hin zum Thema Intelligent Tutoring, was in den 80er Jahren eine große Rolle gespielt hat, dann lange Zeit in Vergessenheit geriet, heute wieder sehr en vogue ist.
Was bezeichnet das?
Naja die Möglichkeit, den Computer als Lehrer einzusetzen, der nicht nur mechanisch reagiert, sondern auch eigene Vorschläge macht.
Also interaktive Prozesse auch ermöglicht?
Ja der in gewisser Weise an menschliche Intelligenz heranreicht. Das war in den 80er Jahren sehr populär, intelligent tutoring und darüber ging auch meine Habilitation. In diesem Bereich war ich da tätig, Systeme zu entwickeln, zu programmieren, in Programmiersprachen, die man heute kaum noch verwendet, wie Lisp und Prolog zu Beispiel.
Ach die kommen schon wieder in en vogue.
Ich habe sie lange nicht mehr benutzt jetzt, aber ich habe sogar Bücher zu dem Thema geschrieben und kam dann eben in diese Schiene rein und so wurde die Linguistik für mich quasi das Trägerelement, was es zu vermitteln gab. Aber den Hintergrund bildete dann oft in vielen Bereichen auch schon der Computer. Den Hintergrund bildete der Computer.
Das heißt Sie haben dann wann die Professorenstelle hier konkret angetreten?
1991.
91. Und war das dann von Anfang an für Sie auch schon ein Werkzeug? War das schon von Vornherein etwas was Sie mit eingepreist haben in Ihre Arbeit?
Ja ich habe ja eine Zwitterstelle von Anfang an. Die Kollegen, die damals diese Stelle geschaffen haben, haben wenn man es heute vielleicht so sieht, einen großen Weitblick, den die haben, gesagt, der Mann, der diese Stelle bekleidet oder die Frau soll Linguistik sein, aber auch, und damals nannte man das so, linguistische Datenverarbeitung. Also ich hab eine zweigeteilte Stelle. Und linguistische Datenverarbeitung war das deutsche Wort für eben Computer, computational linguistics. Das wurde dann im Laufe der Zeit dann anders. Mittlerweile würde ich sagen, ist meine Stelle nach wie vor Linguistik und Web-Technology. Ich bin sozusagen ein zweigeteilter Mensch, habe eine zweigeteilte Stelle.
Wie kam es denn zu dieser Ausschreibung?
Das war das Ziel der Kolleginnen und Kollegen damals. Die sagten, wir wollen hier als Anglistik-Institut in den Bereich der Computer vordringen. Als ich herkam gab es einen einzigen Computer, der stand im Sekretariat 1991 und dann sehr schnell haben wir dann quasi es erreicht, dieses Institut technologisch nach vorn zu bringen, sage ich mal.
Sie haben dann in der Folge das dann auch konkret getan und arbeiten heute mit einem verhältnismäßig großen Technologieeinsatz in der Lehre. Das heißt bei Ihnen ist sozusagen das digitale Element nicht nur ein Zusatz, sondern sozusagen steht auch im Mittelpunkt des Schaffens und alles – also nicht alles orientiert sich daran, aber – alles wird sozusagen auch mit diesen Mitteln und Wegen gedacht und haben zahlreiche ungewöhnliche oder zumindest nicht besonders populäre Methoden eingeführt. Da wollen wir auch gleich nochmal drüber sprechen. Für Ihre Arbeit sind Sie ja auch ausgezeichnet worden vom Stifterverband für die deutsche Wissenschaft, gemeinsam mit der Hochschullehrerkonferenz, den Ars Legendi Preis 2015 für exzellente Hochschullehre.
Was hat Sie denn, ich meine als Sie begonnen haben, ich stelle mir das jetzt mal so vor, wenn man so neu ist auch in so einem System, da muss man da ja auch erst mal mit dem arbeiten was da ist beziehungsweise man ist ja dann auch umringt mit Leuten, die es quasi nie anders getan haben. Und man übernimmt ja dann erst mal zwangsläufig auch das und kriegt wahrscheinlich auch erst mal nicht sehr viel mehr Ratschläge als, das musst du so machen, das haben wir schon immer so getan. Von daher nehme ich an, dass Sie das auch erst mal einfach erst mal eine Weile auch so betrieben haben?
Ja also als ich hier ankam war die erste Innovation, die für mich eine Innovation war, war die Benutzung eines Programms, ich weiß nicht, ob man das heute noch kennt, namens Havard Graphics, das war der Vorläufer von PowerPoint. Und mir gelang es, auf diesem Programm meine bis dato handgezeichneten Folien nun auch am Computer zu machen. Ich hatte hier einen für viel Geld angeschafften Farbdrucker, den ich aus meinen Berufungsmitteln mir besorgt hatte und mir gelang es eben, Folien farblich auszudrucken. Die waren schrecklich bunt damals. Man ist dann sehr schnell…
Man übertreibt ja immer gerne.
Ja ich bin abgefahren auch in gewisser Weise. Ich glaube der Behaltenseffekt bei den Studierenden muss groß gewesen sein, so bunt wie die waren. Und die habe ich dann auf einen Overheadprojektor aufgelegt, das war die erste Innovation. Und die Studenten haben gestaunt. Wie macht man so was? Und das war noch vor PowerPoint. Danach hatte ich dann PowerPoint in Einsatz gebracht und mir gelang es, ein Overhead-Display zu besorgen. Ich weiß nicht, ob Sie das noch kennen, man legte das auf den Overheadprojektor, konnte dann mit einem tragbaren Computer, Laptop gab es auch noch nicht, man musste das alles in den Hörsaal wuchten, konnte man diese Bilder an die Wand werfen.
Also so ein durchsichtiger LCD-Bildschirm im Prinzip.
Ja das war aber nur in zwei Farben. Der Raum musste abgedunkelt werden. Ich weiß nicht, ob es überhaupt, die sind wahrscheinlich alle eingeschlafen, ich konnte die gar nicht mehr sehen. Aber ich hatte diese Folien an der Wand. Eine Innovation ohnegleichen. Ich weiß nicht, ob es wahrgenommen wurde überhaupt. Man hat mich vielleicht schwitzend über den Flur laufen sehen mit den vielen Geräten. Und das ging ja dann weiter, ein paar Jahre später gab es dann die ersten Datenprojektoren. Das Wort Beamer kannte man noch gar nicht. Ich hatte da mal einen, der war gefühlte 30kg schwer, der hatte die satte Kapazität von 200 Lumen. Wiederum musste der Raum verdunkelt werden und diesmal kam noch etwas dazu, ich weiß gar nicht, ob die Studierenden mich überhaupt gehört haben, weil das Lüftergeräusch war so groß, das hat alles übertönt. Aber ich hatte was neues wieder und konnte was machen, wovon ich überzeugt war, das würde etwas bringen im Vergleich zur klassischen Methode, zum Beispiel dem Tafelanschrieb. Das war die Idee.
Und wieder ein paar Jahre später haben wir ja dann selbst CD-Roms entwickelt. Wir waren glaube ich die ersten auf dem Markt, die wissenschaftliche CDs hergestellt haben. Die waren auch kommerziell sogar recht erfolgreich und wurden viele viele tausend Male verkauft. Introduction to Linguistics, Introductions to Phonetics and Phonology und kamen gut an. Nur hatten wir eine wahnsinnige Idee, die Idee nämlich, wir könnten diese CDs einfach unseren Studierenden geben und sagen, nun lernt mal schön. Das war eine völlige Fehleinschätzung.
Weil nicht genug Computer vorhanden sind, in den Händen der Studenten?
Nein, weil das Medium allein ist ja nicht das Lernen. Ich glaube, das haben viele übersehen, die heute Massive Open Online Courses anbieten. Die meinen, ein paar Videos und ein bisschen Multiple Choice drumherum das sei lernen. Aber das ist nicht genug. Das haben wir damals einsehen müssen, wir wurden schwer angegriffen. Außerdem stand auch noch in der Presse so etwas wie, Hanke schafft Professorenstellen ab durch Computer. Mit diesem Label musste ich Jahre lang leben. Ich kann mich nicht erinnern, dass bis heute eine Professorenstelle in Deutschland abgeschafft wurde, nur weil digitalisiert wurde. Im Gegenteil, wir haben neue Stellen bekommen. Aber dieses Menetekel hing mir Jahre lang an. Ich würde versuchen, hier mit Technologie Menschen zu ersetzen. Und dabei war das Ziel immer nur, etwas von dem ich überzeugt war, dass es klassisch nicht gut funktioniert, zu verbessern.
Schauen wir doch erst mal auf das, was vielleicht nicht so gut funktioniert hat. Also die traditionelle Lehre, wie sie eben noch sehr verbreitet ist. Üblicherweise gibt es halt Vorlesungen und der oder die Hochschullehrerin hat halt mit einem Rudel Studenten so eine definierte Zeit und dort wird dann halt Inhalt vermittelt. Hat uns ja immerhin Autos und Flugzeuge und Raketenwissenschaft gebracht, kann ja so schlecht nicht gewesen sein, denke ich mal.
Nein. Ja es hat nur für mich einen Haken, ich will ein Beispiel nennen. Ich gebe hier an dieser Universität seit ich hier bin eine Lehrveranstaltung, die heißt the History of English. Seit 1991. Das ist eine Lehrveranstaltung, die Themen behandelt, wo sich so viel nicht verändert hat. Frühe Phasen der englischen Sprache sind so wie sie sind und die sind auch seit 20 Jahren so. Was hinzugekommen ist sind neue Forschungsergebnisse zum Bereich der Sprachentwicklung des Menschen im Allgemeinen, vom Homo Erectus über die frühe Menschwerdung. Was hinzu gekommen ist sind vielleicht einige neue Erkenntnisse über frühere Aussprachen, durch heutige technische Methoden, aber im wesentlichen ist die Lehrveranstaltung so geblieben. Das heißt ich habe seit 1991 50 mal, nein immer nur alle zwei Semester gebe ich die Veranstaltung, also 25 mal diese Lehrveranstaltung gehalten und nach etwa 15 mal ist mir bewusst geworden, ich erzähle jedes Jahr das gleiche.
Und da habe ich gesagt, das ist doch eigentlich eine Verschwendung meiner Kapazität, wenn ich immer das gleiche im Hörsaal erzähle jahraus jahrein. Und ich musste zusätzlich feststellen, durch diese Vorlesung, bei der im Schnitt und die Studierendenzahlen stiegen, anfänglich saß ich mit 25 Studierenden da, heute sind es jetzt fast 200. Bei 200 Studierenden, da meldet sich keiner, da gibt es keine Rückfragen, da passiert überhaupt nicht viel im Hörsaal. Da tragen Sie vor, Sie reden wie gegen eine Wand, in den letzten Reihen bringt man heutzutage seinen Facebook-Account in Ordnung, man twittert, man sitzt einfach nur da. Und als ich das so merkte vor einigen Jahren, so zu Beginn des neuen Jahrtausends, da habe ich mir gedacht, das macht mich nicht gerade sehr glücklich. Das ist nicht eine Lehre, die ich mit Herzblut vertreten kann. Und so habe ich mir überlegt, wie ich diesen Hörsaal aktiver hinbekommen.
Und das war sozusagen der Startschuss kurz nach der Jahrtausendwende, dass wir gesagt haben, wir wollen die Inhalte dieses Kurses und wir haben wirklich mit diesem Kurs begonnen, die wollen wir mal digital darstellen. Damals war das auf CD-Rom-Basis Multimedia. Sie kennen vielleicht diese CD-Rom-Produktionen mit viel viel Aufwand, mit Musik im Hintergrund, das haben wir dann etwas kleiner gemacht und wir hatten ja dann schon das Internet und haben entsprechende Lerneinheiten gebaut. Und nach einigen Jahren haben wir dann festgestellt, jetzt sind die eigentlich digital ganz gut. Haben wir unseren Studierenden diese Lerneinheiten angeboten.
Wer ist digital gut? Die Produktion oder die Studenten?
Die Produktion. Die Produktion ist soweit in Ordnung, ist ein gehöriges Maß an Interaktivität drin. Das war ungefähr 2004 bis 2006. Ich hatte damals immer gesagt, das Internet ist mir eigentlich viel zu leise, heute würde ich sagen, ist mir zu laut. Aber damals war ja Sound im Internet eine Sensation. Und wir hatten das schon. Wir konnten also Sounddarstellungen machen, wir konnten Dinge machen, die wir in der klassischen Lehre nicht tun konnten.
Was ja jetzt auch gerade im Bereich Linguistik ja auch nochmal …
Musikwissenschaft, Linguistik, das sind so Disziplinen, wo Sie den Sound brauchen. Physik geht auch ohne Sound. Es sei denn, Sie wollen Explosionsgeräusche oder irgendwie so was messen. Aber Linguistik ohne Sound ist einfach unmöglich. Sprache ist das Trägermedium. Und wir hatten das. So und dann haben wir diesen Kurs entwickelt, von der ersten bis zur 14. Sitzung, wir haben ja 14 Semesterwochen, haben unseren Studierenden diese digitalen Inhalte über eine eigens entwickelte Plattform zur Verfügung gestellt und haben uns dann überlegt, was machen wir jetzt eigentlich in der Präsenzphase? Wir können ja schlecht das was wir digital haben einfach vor deren Augen durchklicken.
Oder ein Video abspielen oder so.
Ja Video abspielen, sich daneben stellen und sagen, ach jetzt …
Willkommen im Hochschulkino.
... gucken wir mal 15 Minuten. Das war uns schon frühzeitig bewusst. Also haben wir erst folgendes versucht, wir haben gesagt, naja wenn wir dann Zeit haben, dann setzen wir mal richtig einen drauf und machen was neues noch, neue Inhalte. Das Ergebnis war, dass in der damaligen Evaluation, das war 2006, die Studierenden uns gesagt haben, also die sind wohl verrückt geworden, wir müssen hier doppelt so viel machen wie bisher und viel mehr als in anderen Kursen, das geht so nicht. Ein Jahr später haben wir das wieder gemacht und dann haben wir aber nicht viel drauf gesetzt, sondern haben einfach das gleiche was digital vorlag nochmal wiederholt in der Präsenzphase. Und da haben die Studierenden wieder über uns geurteilt nicht sehr positiv und haben gesagt, das hatten wir doch schon, warum kommen wir denn überhaupt? Und damals bestand Präsenzpflicht. Da waren wir wieder abgestraft. Und so kamen wir allmählich in so ein Modell hinein, wo wir sagten, naja was neues machen können wir nur in gewissen Rahmen und nur wiederholen können wir auch nur in gewissen Rahmen.
Und so kamen wir in eine Präsenzphase hinein, die letztlich das realisiert, was man heute den Inverted Classroom nennt, nämlich diese Vertiefungsphase. Wo wir auf der Basis der digital vermittelten Inhalte die Inhalte vertiefen.
Wie findet das dann statt? Also erst mal Inverted Classroom oder umgedrehtes Klassenzimmer das ist sozusagen das wo man normalerweise im Klassenraum erst mal die Wissensvermittlung, die Basiswissensvermittlung gemacht hat und dann gehen alle nach Hause und sollen damit mal ihre Hausarbeit mal anwenden, dreht sich das quasi um. Man sagt, Wissensvermittlung das könnt ihr alleine machen, dazu müsst ihr nicht gemeinsam in einem Raum sitzen und dann habt ihr auch sagen wir mal ein viel flexibleres Zeitmanagement letztlich ja auch, könnt das machen wo und wann und wie ihr wollt, weil wichtig ist nur, dass die Information ankommt, aber dann das Anwenden und das konkrete Schlüsse ziehen und mit anderem Wissen verquicken und interaktiv arbeiten, das macht man ja dann auch sehr viel besser in so einem begleiteten Modell, wo sowohl die Präsenz der Professoren hilfreich sein kann oder der wissenschaftlichen Mitarbeiter, als eben auch die Präsenz der anderen Studenten.
Genau. Also völlig richtig gesagt. Der Begriff Inverted Classroom oder umgedrehtes Klassenzimmer trifft ja so genau eigentlich nicht mittlerweile sage ich immer, wir verschieben die Lehr- und Lernaktivitäten auf einer Zeitachse, das ist ja was wir letztlich machen. Wir drehen ja nicht das Klassenzimmer auf den Kopf. Das bleibt ja nach wie vor, nur wir machen dort eine andere Aktivität heute. Also die zentrale Aktivität der Inhaltsvermittlung und Inhaltserschließung findet vorher statt. Dann wenn man das durch hat trifft man sich in einem Hörsaal und vertieft die Inhalte. Und früher hat man die Inhalte halt allein vertieft in Form von Hausaufgaben, in Form von Datenanalysen, die man allein oder auch in kleinen Lerngruppen ja gemacht hat, aber nachträglich. Heute macht man es im Klassenraum. Und dort ist in der Tat ein sehr sehr kreatives interaktives Szenario. Es ist dort zum Beispiel auch sehr laut. Das ist eine ganz andere Präsenzphase als früher.
Man steht nicht mehr vorne und vermittelt etwas, ich bin Teil des Publikums geworden. Ein sehr schöner Begriff, den gestern ein Studierender geprägt hat, die Präsenzphase ist ein kreatives Gewusel. Finde ich sehr schön den Begriff, der trifft das total gut. Es ist anders, es ist lauter, es ist anstrengender, aber für die Studierenden ist es unglaublich kreativ und für die Lehrenden auch.
Was macht man denn dann in der Präsenzphase? Also was für Aktivitäten lassen sich denn jetzt realisieren, jetzt wo man quasi die Zeit dafür gewonnen hat? Wie bringt man vor allem das Wissen dann sozusagen konkret ein, was vorher erworben wurde?
Also man muss natürlich zunächst mal die Präsenzphase zu Beginn muss man den Studierenden erst mal sagen worum es geht. Also das heißt, man stellt Lernziele vor, man stellt vor, was sie wissen müssen zu diesem Stadium und dann geht man in eine Übungsphase. Wir haben ja dieses spezielle Modell, dass wir vor der Präsenzphase, also zwischen Präsenzphase und digitaler Phase einen Test schalten, dieser Test, ein computergestützter Test, den absolvieren die Studierenden, die Testergebnisse liegen uns vor der Präsenzphase vor und wir wissen, mit welchem Vorbereitungsniveau die Studierenden in diese Präsenzphase kommen. Das ist ganz wichtig. Ich kann nicht einfach nur die digitalen Materialien bereitstellen und dann in die Präsenzphase gehen. Das war das, was wir damals auch mit den CDs ja gespürt haben, das reicht nicht allein. Sondern wir müssen irgendwas dazwischen schalten, einen Test oder weitere Abfragen oder irgend etwas.
Bei uns ist das ein Test. Diese Testergebnisse, wir nennen das den Mastery Level, das ist der Vorbereitungslevel mit dem die Studierenden in die Präsenzphase kommen, der liegt übrigens im Schnitt zwischen 60 und 70%. Das heißt 60% der Studierenden, die kommen in die Präsenzphase, die heute nicht mehr verpflichtend ist, sind vorbereitet, 40% aber nicht. Darf man nie vergessen. Wenn Sie davon ausgehen, dass die Präsenzphase im Schnitt sowieso nur von etwa 70% der Studierenden besucht wird, und das ist ein hoher Wert in der heutigen Zeit der abgeschafften Präsenzpflicht, dann können Sie davon ausgehen, dass jeder 10. unvorbereitet da ist. Also von 10 Studierenden sind 9 vorbereitet und einer nicht. Diesen einen könnten wir theoretisch namentlich identifizieren, tun das aber nicht, aber wir merken es sofort, wenn wir durch die Reihen marschieren. Mit wir meine ich, meine Tutorinnen und Tutoren und ich. Wenn wir durch die Reihen marschieren und sehen, da hat einer Schwierigkeiten mit den gestellten Aufgaben.
Und dem können wir dann individuell helfen und sagen, woran hat es gelegen, was können wir tun, und wo fehlt es, das spüren wir sehr schnell. Also es ist eine hochgradig interaktive Präsenzphase. Wenn ich früher vor 100 Studierenden eine Vorlesung gehalten habe, dann haben vielleicht drei eine Frage gestellt, wenn überhaupt und das waren immer die gleichen drei über das Semester gesehen. Heute rede ich im Schnitt pro Präsenzphase bei 100 Studierenden mit etwa 60 Studierenden persönlich.
Was natürlich auch eine ganz andere soziale Nähe schafft.
Das ist total schwierig. Also auf der einen Seite, man steht nicht mehr vorne hinter einem Pult und verschanzt sich, sondern man ist ganzkörpermäßig zu sehen. Die Studierenden sehen auch, ob meine Schuhe geputzt sind oder nicht, das haben die vorher nie gesehen. Das sind ganz banale Dinge. Also man macht sich quasi nackig vor den Studierenden. Man ist sichtbar, man ist präsent, man steht einen Meter vor den Studierenden. Wenn man schlechtes Deo benutzt, merken die das auch. Also es sind völlig neue Dinge, die da reinkommen. Der Nähe zu den Studierenden, man ist auch körperlich sehr angestrengt, man muss sich auch runterducken, weil man ja auf Augenhöhe mit den Studierenden sein will und nicht wie der große Zampano davorsteht. Es ist eine völlig neue Lehrerrolle, die übrigens in den 90er Jahren schon von einer Medienpädagogin namens Alison King beschrieben wurde. Und sie hat damals gesagt, die Entwicklung wird dahin gehen, dass man sagt, from "Sage on the Stage", also von dem Weisen auf der Bühne, to "Guide on the Side", zum Begleiter an der Seite. Und genau die Rolle ist heute für mich Realität geworden.
Damit werden ja auch Hierarchien abgebaut?
Total. Also ich bin nicht mehr der Gralshüter des Wissens. Ich sage den Studierenden sowieso, das was wir heute wissen steht im Internet, das ist nicht mehr in meinem Kopf. In meinem Kopf ist nur noch ein Teil davon. Aber wenn ihr etwas ganz genau wissen wollt, ihr habt sowieso bei mir ihre digitalen Devices dabei. Also bring your own Device, Smartphone, Tablet, Laptop ist bei mir Pflicht in meinen Veranstaltungen und es wird gegoogelt ohne Ende. Es wird auch mal der private Facebook-Account gepflegt. Auch das habe ich schon gesehen, und dann sage ich den Studierenden, okay wenn ihr die Aufgaben verstanden habt, bitte sehr.
Ich würde gerne nochmal ein bisschen konkreter reingehen, um so ein Gefühl dafür zu bekommen, wie dieser Zyklus so abläuft. Vielleicht können wir uns ja auch mal ein konkreteres Beispiel herausgreifen, eine Aufgabe, die jetzt sozusagen so einmal diesen ganzen Roundtrip an der Stelle beschreibt. Womit beginnt es? Also man formuliert jetzt erst mal das Thema, beziehungsweise es ist ja in dem Sinne auch schon vorbereitet.
Sie meinen die Präsenzphase?
Nein, ich meine eigentlich alles. Also es muss ja erst mal das Wissen muss ja sozusagen vermittelt werden, aber es wird eben nicht in der Präsenzphase vermittelt, sondern in Form von Videos?
Ja wir haben ja eine große Plattform, the Virtual Linguistics Campus, die haben wir seit 2000 entwickelt.
Das ist eine eigene Entwicklung?
Ja, der Hintergrund ist folgender, es gab zwischen 2000 und 2003 das große bundesweite Projekt, neue Medien in der Hochschullehre, damals unter Edelgard Bulmahn noch als Bildungsministerien, von den UMTS-Lizenzen finanziert. Es wurden 240 Millionen Euro in die Hand genommen, DM damals noch, 480 Millionen, und es wurden insgesamt 113 Projekte gefördert bundesweit. Ich weiß konkret nur von zweien, die überlebt haben. Das ist einmal die Fachhochschule Lübeck mit ihren verschiedenen Onlineprojekten und wir. Und wir hatten die vergleichsweise geringe Summe von 240.000 Euro bekommen. Und wir haben aber ein Ziel, das in den Ausschreibungen drin stand, realisiert, nämlich das Schaffen einer geeignete Lernumgebung. Das Wort Lernplattform kannte noch niemand. Also mussten wir eine Umgebung definieren. Und das ist seitdem der Virtual Lingustics Campus. Es ist heute eine funktionierende Lernplattform, die weit über das hinausgeht, was universitätseigene Plattformen können.
Aber sie ist sehr spezialisiert auf ein einzelnes Fach. Und in dieser Lernplattform, da haben wir nun über die Jahre die ganzen Inhalte erzeugt. Und die Inhalte bestehen aus, sind im Prinzip das was manche Medienpädagogen die Krone der Digitalisierung nennen, es sind multimediale Inhalte. Das heißt die Studierenden haben, wenn sie ein Thema bearbeiten, immer die Wahl. Sie können einfach die Texte lesen, die da drin stehen. Sie können mit dem System interagieren, indem sie Mausklicks machen, Texteingaben machen, kleine Quizzes lösen. Sie können aber auch die dort drin verzahnten Videos gucken. Also  es ist praktisch das ganze Arsenal der Möglichkeiten da. Und es gibt ja Studierende, die schauen lieber Videos. Es gibt Studierende, die lesen lieber Texte. Es gibt Studierende, die arbeiten gern mit Quizzes. Also diese Möglichkeiten hat man.
Also es gibt auch nicht, man hat sozusagen auch ein bisschen die Wahl. Also es gibt nicht so das eine Datenpaket, das müssen alle einmal durchmachen, sondern man bietet im Prinzip auch verschiedene Optionen an, um sich an die verschiedenen Lernbevorzugungen sage ich mal der einzelnen Leute, also es gibt Leute, die sind mehr visuell, ich kenne das auch selber. Jeder kann da tatsächlich das raus suchen, was angemessen. Aber es vermittelt am Ende immer dasselbe Wissen?
Genau. Und wir bieten zusätzlich gewisse Lernpfade an. Das sind Leitfragen, die einen durch diese Lerneinheit führen. Es gibt Material drumherum zum Vertiefen, schon vor der Präsenzphase. Es gibt das, was wir unseren Interactive Tutore nennen. Das geht zurück auf meine Erfahrungen mit Intelligent Tutoring aus den 80er Jahren. Das sind verschiedene Testszenarien, in denen man überprüfen kann, habe ich das verstanden ja oder nein. Es sind Verlinkungen in Google Translate hinein. Also gerade für Sprache ja auch wichtig. Also es sind ganz viele kleine, wir haben Online Lexika im Hintergrund, die mit semantischen Webs arbeiten. Da kommt die Computerlinguistik hinein. Wir haben Analyseprogramme, die Texteingaben in Quizzes analysieren. Also die nicht nur sagen, falsch oder richtig, sondern die auch bei Vertippern zum Beispiel durchaus Antworten als richtig akzeptieren. Also da steckt dieses Computerlinguistik Knowhow mit drin.
Also es ist ganz viel in den einzelnen Lerneinheiten über die Jahre zusammen gekommen und ich denke, so mittlerweile haben wir ein Level erreicht, wo wir sagen können, so könnte es super und so funktioniert es zunächst mal recht gut.
Und im Prinzip ist ja auch der komplette Studiengang so in der Form dann digitalisiert worden.
Ja.
Sowohl mit seinen ganzen Quellen, mit dem Wissen, mit den Lehrmethoden, den Tests, den Vertiefungseinheiten, was ja sagen wir auch mal ein interessantes Gut ist, weil sich ja so Studiengänge selbst ja eigentlich gar nicht dokumentieren sollen. Eigentlich immer nur durch das tradierte erlernte Wissen der Einzelakteure immer wieder vorgetragen am Leben erhalten hat. Aber um nochmal etwas konkreter da den Ablauf nachzuspüren, also mit dem Virtual Linguistic Campus gestaltet man quasi auch als Lehrender die Arbeit. Und jetzt sagen wir mal, ein Semester hat begonnen, ich bin jetzt hier vielleicht im ersten Semester, was wäre jetzt so das erste, was ich so als Lerneinheit, was würde mir so als erstes entgegenkommen?
Also die Erstsemester sind zunächst mal überrascht, was sie hier vorgesetzt bekommen.
Ja kann ich mir vorstellen.
Die sind also, das läuft so ab, wir beginnen mal in einem Wintersemester, 01. Oktober, da werden unsere Kurse freigeschaltet, das heißt ab dann kommt man an alles ran, von der ersten bis zur letzten Sitzung. Der Haken ist, die Erstsemester kommen erst am 10. Oktober und da läuft das Semester fast schon. Also müssen wir uns eine kleine Zeit gönnen, um die Erstsemester zunächst mal vorzubereiten auf diese neue Digitalisierungsmaschinerie, die wir da entwickelt haben. Und so dauert es dann etwa 10 Tage bis sie wissen woran sie sind. Und danach …
Das heißt es beginnt sozusagen damit, dass erst mal Zugänge geschaffen werden, man kann drauf zugreifen am 01. Oktober präsentiert sich quasi die Uni bereits digital, obwohl die Türen noch verschlossen sind?
So ist es. Und die Erstsemester müssen sich ja erst mal ein Konto anlegen in der Lernplattform. Das dauert seine Zeit, aber dann ist es quasi fast schon ein Selbstläufer. Denn die heutigen Erstsemester, das sind ja diejenigen, die man mit diesem Wort Digital Natives belegt. Das heißt ja, das sind Menschen, die mit einem Smartphone groß geworden sind.
Denen man nicht erklären muss, was ein Account ist.
Genau. Und aber die haben nicht viel Medienkompetenz, aber eine sehr hohe Medienbedienkompetenz. Und die kommen, für die ist das kein Thema und wenn sie dann die Nachricht bekommen, sie sollen ihre Geräte mitbringen, dann sind sie zunächst mal überrascht, weil sie es ja in der Schule nicht durften. Aber dann geht das sehr schnell und mittlerweile, das ist auch ein tolles Bild, wenn ich in meinem Hörsaal stehe und habe 140-150 Erstsemester da sitzen, die haben fein säuberlich aufgereiht die Smartphones vor sich liegen oder auch die Tabletts, Tabletts nicht, die Notebooks, Tabletts werden sehr überschätzt meiner Ansicht nach. Wir fragen das auch immer wieder ab, Notebooks oder Smartphones sind die Geräte, die sie einsetzen. Und dann kommen sie in die erste Sitzung und siehe da, sie sind vorbereitet. Das Vorbereitungsniveau bei Erstsemestern in der allerersten Sitzung liegt etwa um die 50-60%, das sind unsere Erfahrungen.
Und das ist ein super Wert, dafür dass man die ja noch nie gesehen hat. Die kommen zum ersten Mal, sehen mich das erste Mal und ich sage ihnen gleich so, dann können wir anfangen zu üben. Ganz so drastisch ist es nicht, also ich stelle mich schon ein bisschen vor, und die Tutoren und wir erklären, wer wir sind und welchen Hintergrund wir haben. Aber im Prinzip kommen wir hinein in den Hörsaal und sie haben schon dieses Inverted Classroom ja noch nicht verinnerlicht, aber schon mal in einem ersten Schritt angewendet. Und danach ist es ein Selbstläufer.
Was lerne ich denn da jetzt so gleich zum Start? Was ist denn so eine Wissenseinheit, mit der man sich für die erste Präsenzsitzung vorbereiten muss?
Also in der allerersten Sitzung der Lehrveranstaltung Introduction to Linguistics lernen sie den Unterschied zwischen Sprache und Kommunikation. Sie lernen, warum sie überhaupt Linguistik studieren sollen. Was das soll, denn viele, die ein Fach wie Englisch studieren, die denken, sie setzen sich ausschließlich mit Shakespeare auseinander und mit Literatur ein bisschen über London. Und nun kommt jemand und sagt, ihr habt da Linguistik, die wissen ja gar nicht was das ist. Und wir schaffen eine Sensibilisierung durch, so hoffen wir, interessante Sprachbeispiele. Also Beispiele wie, wenn ich Ihnen eines meiner Lieblingsbeispiele ist immer, wenn ich vor einer 20-jährigen Studentin stehe und ihr sage, Sie haben vielleicht am Samstag eine Fete, wie würden Sie reagieren, wenn ich sage, ich komme zu Ihrer Fete? Ich Jürgen Hanke, 61 Jahre alt. Dann kommt sie sehr schnell drauf, dass das nicht unbedingt ein Versprechen ist, sondern auch eine Warnung sein kann.
Und da schafft man Bewusstsein für in diesem Fall ein Gebiet der Linguistik, das man Pragmatik nennt. Und so können Sie viele Beispiele erst mal den Studierenden bringen, wo sie plötzlich feststellen, au backe das ist ja ganz interessant, aber in der Schule habe ich nie was drüber gehört. Also das passiert in dieser ersten Sitzung. Und dann geht es natürlich weiter in die einzelnen Teilgebiete der Linguistik.
Und dieses Wissen wird jetzt sozusagen vermittelt primär über Videos zunächst einmal? Was sehe ich dann? Sie.
Videos, Multimedia. Ja in den Videos sehen Sie, es gibt mehrere Arten von Videos. Wir haben die – ja klassisch hört sich jetzt etwas überspitzt an, aber ich sage schon mal – die klassische e-Lecture, die electronic Lecture, das ist eine Vorlesung, die ohne Publikum speziell mit einem Skript sehr kompakt vor einer Kamera gehalten wird, ausgerichtet auf das Medium Video. Nicht auf ein Publikum, das vor einem sitzt. Obwohl man auch in einer e-Lecture so tut als säße da ein Publikum.
Also monologisch.
Genau. Das ist also eine electronic Lecture, eine e-Lecture, die hat selten eine Länge von mehr als 15-20 Minuten. Also mehr ist auch nicht verkraftbar, weil die ja auch so kompakt gestaltet ist, dass sie in der Echtzeit etwa 40-45 Minuten sagt man im allgemeinen, durchaus abdecken könnte. Das heißt mit 2 e-Lectures könnte ich eine 90-minütige klassische Veranstaltung schon mal ersetzen. Wir machen das aber nicht so, wir haben meistens eine E-Lecture und dann eine Anzahl von 3-5 Microlectures dabei. Microlectures sind kleine Lehrvideos, die maximal eine Länge bei uns zumindest von 2 Minuten haben. Die punktuell in sehr dynamischen Präsentationen Themen vorstellen. die entweder wo eine Präsentation am Bildschirm erzeugt wird, das kann auch so eine Verschiebetechnik sein, eine Legetechnik, eine Animationstechnik, eine Schreibtechnik.
Da gibt es verschiedene Techniken, solche kleinen Videovorlesungen zu machen. Wir haben auch dann noch eine Kooperation mit einem Kanal aus den vereinigten Staaten, die unsere Videoqualität sichern und wir sichern deren Videos gemäß einer guten Qualität. Und wir tauschen Videos aus. Das heißt wir benutzen auch von denen sehr tolle Videos, die wir auch anwerben, genauso wie dieser Kanal unsere Videos weltweit anwirbt. Das ist auch ein Novum, dass so was gemacht wird, dass man Kanalkooperationen trifft mit anderen YouTube-Kanälen.
Mit wem findet das statt?
Nativelang heißt der Kanal, das ist ein sehr schöner Kanal aus den USA, mit dem wir ständig in Kontakt stehen mit den Entwicklern und wir eben diese Videos auch nutzen. Also haben wir dann in dieser Lerneinheit …
Also worin besteht die Qualitätssicherung? Eas ist jetzt aber nicht, dass jetzt irgendwie ein Amerikaner das Englisch überprüft oder so?
Nein, die Inhalte. Also unsere Mitarbeiter gucken sich die Videos von Nativelang an und Nativelang- Leute gucken sich unsere Videos an und sagen, das können wir gebrauchen, das ist gut. Hier könnt ihr nochmal folgende Änderung einfügen und …
Weil ja jeder quasi unabhängig voneinander ja auch auf andere Ideen kommt und andere Erfahrungen sammelt und sagt, ja haben wir auch schon mal probiert, hat nicht funktioniert, dass wir das gemacht haben.
Ja. Und dann sind wir auch bemüht, eben Dinge zu tun, die die anderen nicht machen. Also dieser Kanal in den USA hat jetzt eine sehr interessante Animationstechnik, die wir gar nicht beherrschen und die nutzen wir natürlich, weil das toll ist was die da machen. Und genauso nutzen die die Sachen von uns, die sie nicht beherrschen, weil sie vielleicht nicht den technologischen oder inhaltlichen Hintergrund haben.
Was denn zum Beispiel?
Ja.
Von uns?
Also von uns werden sehr viel unsere Microlectures benutzt. also wir haben zum Beispiel - und das ist auch etwas, was jedes Fach eigentlich machen kann - wir haben unser gesamtes Glossar, Glossarbegriffe aus der Linguistik in kleine Microlectures umgewandelt und dadurch sind die viel dynamischer als eine einfache textuelle Erklärung.
Und lassen sich auch im Prinzip ja jeder Zeit wieder neu kombinieren, in andere Vorträge mit einbauen, so dass man sagen kann, okay hier komplett neues Gebiet, aber Glossare sind nun mal eben die Begriffe, die immer wiederkehren und die muss man ja auch nicht nochmal erklären, haben wir halt schon ein fertiges Video.
Brauche ich mich nicht mehr in den Hörsaal stellen und sagen …
Das lässt sich natürlich dadurch auch sehr viel besser aktualisieren, weil wenn es jetzt tatsächlich mal bei so einem Begriff zu irgendeinem Novum kommt, durch ein neues Forschungsergebnis oder durch eine andere kulturelle Bedeutung, die irgendwas erlangt hat, dann aktualisiert man das und hat automatisch auch alle anderen Sachen vorliegen.
Genau. Und das ist ja so ein zwei Minuten-Video das ersetzt man dann halt. Wenn da sich herausstellt, das war nicht so toll oder da ist irgendein Fehler unterlaufen, das kann man leicht ersetzen, das spielt dann keine Rolle.
Und so wird dann die Lehre quasi auch die ganze Zeit immer besser.
Ja ich denke auch, wir updaten das. Mittlerweile wir haben begonnen mit der Videoproduktion 2012, und mittlerweile denke ich darüber nach, die ersten Videos neu aufzulegen, die damals gemacht wurden. Und das liegt nicht notwendigerweise an den Inhalten. Es liegt mittlerweile an der Erkenntnis, dass ich es vielleicht kompakter hinbekommen könnte und dass auch die Technik, die Videotechnik, die wir jetzt drauf haben, immer besser wird. Also wir kommen mittlerweile in so einen Bereich hinein, das sagten mir neulich Leute, wo wir drüber nachdenken sollten, uns professionelle Kameraleute zur Beratung zu genehmigen, weil die Ansprüche steigen.
Ja.
Ich hatte ursprünglich immer gepredigt, so am Anfang, dass man die Videoproduktion gar nicht so perfekt haben sollte, man ist ja schließlich Lehrer und nicht Videoproduzent. Aber wenn man es lange genug macht, steigen die Ansprüche und dann möchte man es auch immer besser haben. Das ist glaube ich eine natürlich Entwicklung. Und dieser Spruch, den die amerikanischen Kollegen, mit denen ich zusammen gearbeitet habe uns ins Kontor geschrieben haben, die haben nämlich gesagt, do you need the Video perfect or do you need it by tuesday? Und da haben wir immer gesagt, ja bis Dienstag das reicht. Aber mittlerweile reicht es nicht mehr so ganz. Wir wollen es schon ein bisschen besser haben jetzt. Und diese Ansprüche, die sieht man auch bundesweit. Auch in Deutschland gibt es ja verschiedene Videoproduzenten und die werden immer besser die Videos.
Ich denke das hat auch ein bisschen was mit den Sehgewohnheiten zu tun. Ich meine, man will sich ja wahrscheinlich auch nicht ewig und sagen wir auch mal mit einem ändernden Duktus, den man auch so annimmt. Also man spricht ja heutzutage auch anders, als man es vor 10 oder 20 Jahren gemacht hat. Ich meine, ich erinnere mich jetzt noch – das werden Sie ja sicherlich auch noch kennen aus den, ich weiß gar nicht, wann das anfing, in den 80er Jahren, diese lustigen informativen Telekollegsendungen, die damals im dritten Fernsehen immer liefen.
Ja, Professor Dr. Bersch, Mathematik.
Kennen Sie da den Hintergrund eigentlich, wo diese Sendungen real zum Einsatz kamen? Also wer das nicht kennt, es gab tatsächlich damals im dritten Fernsehen oder den dritten Fernsehsendern, die ja so regional noch aufgeteilt waren, ich glaube immer so am Nachmittag, diese Telekollegs, wo halt bestimmte Lerninhalte per Fernsehkamera …
Völlig steif.
... genau sehr steif präsentiert wurden. Wo kam denn das zum Einsatz damals?
Ich kenne kein Einsatzszenario. Weil ich habe die selber gesehen und ich war nach drei Minuten abgeschreckt.
Wovon?
Von dieser Steifheit. Da saß jemand am Schreibtisch mit Anzug und Krawatte und hinten wurde was sehr sehr mühsam eingeblendet. Man hatte ja noch nicht die ganze Technik mit der Einblendung und Greenscreentechnik damals. Nehme ich mal, ich weiß nicht, welche Technik man hatte. Aber es war sehr sehr steif. Und so versuchen wir auch, diese Videos eben nicht so steif zu machen. Also wenn jemand sichtbar ist in dem Video, das ist natürlich eine Hürde, die man zu überwinden hat, dann wird mit großer Gestik operiert und nicht steif an einem Tisch gesessen. Man geht hin und her, man wirkt auf das nicht vorhandene Publikum ein, man begrüßt die Leute und …
Ja, wie ist die Ansprache?
Ja ich mache es ja immer auf englisch. Hi, nice to see you. Sage ich, ich sehe ja keinen, aber nice to see you. Und das ist schon anders. Also ist auch anders, als man es im Hörsaal machen würde. Es ist viel lebhafter. Ich muss feststellen, ich bewege meine Arme viel häufiger, wenn ich vor der Kamera stehe, als wenn ich ..
Hat man auch mehr das Gefühl, mit einem – ich meine, im Hörsaal hat man es ja automatisch mit vielen zu tun. Beim Video ist es ja eigentlich immer in der Regel ein Individuum mit dem man spricht.
Man guckt immer nur auf einen Punkt, nämlich auf die Kamera. Im Hörsaal muss ich immer wieder beobachten bei mir, dass ich offenbar nicht alle Studierenden mit gleichen Blickanteilen begünstige und dann stelle ich nach einer halben Stunde fest, oh da rechts vorne hast du ja überhaupt noch nicht hingeguckt. Und das kann einem in so einem Video nicht passieren, man guckt die ja immer an.
Es sei denn, man schaut die ganze Zeit an der Kamera vorbei.
Klar. Aber insofern, die Videos spielen eine wichtige Rolle in der Vorbereitung und ich hatte ja gesagt, diese Microlectures sind wichtige Videoformate.
Nochmal zu den Videos. Sind das jetzt in der Regel wirklich Talking Heads, also ist man immer Person vor der Kamera oder gibt es auch einen bestimmten Videoanteil, der – also Sie sagten ja, es gibt auch Animationen, also es gibt auch Sachen, wo sozusagen nur ein Kommentar aus dem Off gesprochen wird?
Ja, also ich sage ja, bei den e-Lectures, den großen, den 15-minütigen ist man immer sichtbar in unserem Fall. Das mag aber auch fachspezifisch sein. Denn wir haben in diesem Fall Präsentationen, wo manchmal sich über mehrere Minuten sich nicht viel im Hintergrund ändert. Da ist vielleicht ein Tafelanschrieb im Hintergrund zu sehen, aber so viel passiert da nicht und da ist durchaus die Gestik und Mimik des Sprechers und auch die Intonation natürlich wichtig. Es gibt dann Videos, diese kleinen Videos, die Microlectures, da tauchen wir nie drin auf, weil die so schnell und so hoch dynamisch sind, dass ein Sprecherbild nur ablenken würde.
Ja.
Also das sind so die beiden Extrempunkte und dazwischen gibt es natürlich Videos, ich habe auch Videos mit Kollegen gemacht im Dialog, wo man dann aus dem Bild heraustritt der eine und dem anderen das Feld überlässt. Da muss man natürlich beide Menschen erst sehen, das geht gar nicht anders. Es gibt Videos, wo man einfach nur auf einem Laptop schreibt. Das sind Videos, die in der Mathematik zum Beispiel eine ganz große Rolle spielen. Da wird ja nur geschrieben. Ein Mathematiker schreibt in seiner Lehre von links oben bis rechts unten eine gefühlte 50 m² große Tafel voll, dann wischt er sie ab, macht eine Pause und macht das gleiche nochmal. Das werden Sie in der Sprachwissenschaft nie sehen. Und deswegen spielt dort der Videoscribe eine große Rolle, also das Schreiben auf einem Tablet und dabei das sozusagen Abgreifen dieses Inhaltes. Das sind bei uns Videos, die haben wir auch im Bereich er Analyse von Sprachdaten, da haben wir solche Videos. Da taucht natürlich kein Sprecher auf.
Ich würde jetzt nochmal diesen Lehrzyklus machen. Jetzt haben wir ja schon ganz gut festgehalten, was für Materialien jetzt für die Wissensvermittlung generiert werden. Wir sollten vielleicht auch nachher nochmal über die konkreten Umstände davon sprechen und die eingesetzte Technik. Aber wenn jetzt die Studenten diese Videos, diese e-Lectures vor allem oder eben dann die Sonderformen, teilweise aus den Microlectures zusammengesetzt, teilweise aus anderen Sachen, zur Kenntnis genommen haben zu Hause, dann sagten Sie gibt es den zweiten Schritt, wo quasi die Möglichkeit oder auch die Aufforderung oder die Verpflichtung besteht, dieses gelernte Wissen dann auch konkret zu testen. Das findet wieder über dieselbe Webseite statt, über diesen Virtual Linguistic Campus. Das heißt, was präsentiert sich mir dann? Kriegen ich so einen Fragenkatalog und ich muss einfach nachweisen, dass ich jetzt quasi was aufgenommen habe, ist das dann einfach nur so Multiple Choice anklicken oder was?
Das war anfänglich hauptsächlich Multiple Choice. Das ist natürlich eine Testform, die uns selbst sehr gestört hat. In den Geisteswissenschaften Multiple Choice, das ist ein NoGo, das geht gar nicht. Und so hatte ich mir immer auch von Anfang an gesagt, ich muss es ja auch meinen Kolleginnen und Kollegen erklären. Die müssen ja auch wissen, die testen ab sofort elektronisch und habe dann natürlich gewusst, das wird schwierig. Weil wir oft Essay-Klausuren und Essay-Tests machen in unseren Fächern und habe dann in Kenntnis natürlich der Tatsache, dass der Computer das heute noch nicht kann, sie können kein Essay schreiben und den vom Computer bewerten lassen. Mittlerweile gibt es diese Peer-to-Peer-Möglichkeiten, das ist etwas anderes, aber der Computer selbst kann noch keinen Test auswerten. Also mussten wir Testverfahren entwickeln, wo ich meinen Kolleginnen und Kollegen nachweisen konnte, die haben einen Mehrwert gegenüber dem klassischen Test im Hörsaal, also in einem Klausurszenario.
Und das sind in der Sprachwissenschaft Tests, wo Sie Soundunterstützung haben. Es gibt ja keine Klausur, wo Sie Sound hören können. Das ist ja Totenstille in einer Klausur. Und damit konnten wir Mehrwerte zeigen. Also eine Klausur, ein Test, wo Sie vor dem Computer sitzen, Sie hören etwas und werden danach gefragt zu dem was Sie gehört haben. Das geht ja klassisch gar nicht. Das war der Ansatzpunkt, Mehrwerte zu erzeugen. Das was dann abgefragt wurde, war in der Tat in vielen Fällen noch Multiple Choice, aber seit zwei Jahren, seit anderthalb haben wir diese Multiple Choice-Übungen sukzessive ersetzt durch das was wir Dynamic Multiple Choice nennen. Das funktioniert so, Sie bekommen eine Frage gestellt mit vier Antwortmöglichkeiten. Sie sehen aber nur eine dieser vier Antwortmöglichkeiten, die zufälligerweise generiert wird und müssen dann entscheiden, ist das schon die richtige, ohne die drei anderen zu kennen. Das ist ein viel höherer Anspruch.
Weil man immer davon ausgehen muss, dass es auch eine falsche ist.
So ist es, ist die schon gut genug die erste oder wollen sie die zweite sehen. Und dann könnte es aber schon zu spät sein.
Das wird zufällig ausgewählt?
Die wird immer wieder zufällig ausgewählt. Und diese Tests haben unsere Studierenden zum Beispiel zu dem Urteil bewogen, die finden sie aber blöd. Damit ist für uns das beste Qualitätsurteil erzielt worden, denn die Tests sind gut. Die kann man nicht mehr auswendig lernen. Man kann auch nicht mehr wild klicken. Und diese Tests haben noch einen Vorteil. Sie können den Fragenpool viel häufiger verwenden. Denn wenn eine Frage falsch beantwortet ist, kriegen Sie ja nicht den Rest noch gezeigt. Und wenn die Frage neu gestellt wird, kann sie mit einer ganz anderen Struktur gestellt werden. Also Sie haben eigentlich nur Vorteile und das ist ein Test, den haben wir hier wirklich erfunden und ich glaube, der dürfte bundesweit einzigartig sein, aber ist mittlerweile in die Thesen auch zum Prüfen in Hochschulforum Digitalisierung eingeflossen. Dass man sagt, wir müssen von diesem biederen Multiple Choice weg. Also wir sind nicht Günther Jauch und machen Wer wird Millionär, sondern wir haben hier anspruchsvollere Testszenarien.
Wir sind aber noch nicht so weit, wir haben auch Textinput, allerdings nur auf der Basis von einfachen Satzteilen oder Wörtern. Aber da gehen wir weiter, irgendwann werden wir Sätze analysieren, die man eintippen kann.
Wie sieht denn die Auswertung davon aus? Was sieht man denn quasi als Lehrer dann im Ergebnis? Also die Studenten arbeiten ja unter ihren eigenen Accounts und gehen sozusagen durch das ganze Abfrageszenario durch. Sehe ich jetzt bei so einem Dynamic Multiple Choice, wie viele Ansätze, also nur ob es überhaupt eine richtige Antwort gab oder sehe ich sozusagen auch, wie viele falsche raus gelassen wurden?
Nein das sehen wir nicht. Das ist auch wichtig für die Studierenden zu wissen. Falsche Versuche werden nicht abgespeichert. In die Datenbank kommen die Ergebnisse erst dann, wenn der Test bestanden ist. Und dazu gehört ein Niveau von 60%, was überschritten werden muss. Und wenn man die überschritten hat, dann kann man aber weitergehen und man sieht auch den Highscore des jeweiligen Tests, was in den meisten Fällen 100% ist, also irgendeiner wird immer die 100% schaffen. Und das dient vielleicht als Ansporn für viele, den Test dann nochmal zu machen und sein Ergebnis in die Höhe zu hieven.
Ach so, die anderen Studenten sehen auch, das heißt was sozusagen das beste Ergebnis war.
Genau. Aber sie können nicht mehr unter die 60% Hürde fallen. Und das ist ein ganz wichtiges Prinzip. Das habe ich von den Amerikanern mit…
Warum nicht?
Naja man möchte, dieser Satz, den ich gerade sagen wollte, der lautet, don't demonise failure. Also das Versagen nicht zu verteufeln. Den Studierenden immer wieder Chancen zu geben. Manche müssen vielleicht den Test zehn mal machen bis sie ihn bestehen, wir merken davon aber nichts. Und sie kriegen auch immer wieder neue Fragen generiert, weil der Fragenpool wesentlich größer ist als die Fragen, die tatsächlich gestellt werden.
Ah okay, das heißt man kriegt immer wieder eine neue Chance, einen anderen Ausriss sozusagen beantworten zu können, weil niemand kann alles. Aber für die Anforderungen für die Lerneinheit reicht es aus. Und zumindest gibt es genug Ansporn, überhaupt erst mal das Primärwissen sich auch soweit angeschaut zu haben, dass man die Chance hat, das zu können.
Manche machen möglicherweise nur den Test und gucken überhaupt nicht rein in die Lerneinheit. Das gibt es. Die versuchen es einfach, bestehen, sagen okay reicht.
Gab es ja auch schon vorher.
Es gibt auch welche, die ignorieren den Test völlig. Das gibt es, auch das gab es vorher. Der Schnitt ist so, dass wir eben vor Beginn der Präsenzphase etwa irgendwo zwischen im letzten Semester war es in dem Kurs, den ich erwähnt hatte, History of English, waren es 67% das war der durchschnittliche Mastery Level, so nennen wir das. Also 67% der im Kurs registrierten Studierenden hatten diesen Test erfolgreich bestanden. Den jeweiligen.
Bestanden haben sie ihn, wenn sie mindestens 60% der Fragen haben?
Ja.
Und das würden Sie sagen ist eine gute Quote?
Also verglichen mit der klassischen Lehre. Wie war es denn in der klassischen Lehre, man hat gesagt, lesen Sie bitte bis nächsten Donnerstag folgenden Aufsatz oder folgenden Artikel und hat man die Woche danach gefragt, wer hat es gelesen, na wer war es, 2-3% und heute haben wir 67%, das ist schon gigantisch. Also wir sind da sehr stolz drauf auf diesen Vorbereitungslevel, den wir aber gern noch höher hätten, das ist klar.
Wie lässt sich das noch steigern?
Ja indem man vielleicht die Hürde in der Präsenzphase höher setzt und sagt, wer den Test nicht besteht, der hat wirklich keine Chance, hier überhaupt diese 90 Minuten vernünftig zu überstehen. Aber ich weiß es nicht, ob es sich überhaupt steigern lässt. Es ist so ein ähnlicher Wert wie der Wert für die Präsenzteilnahme. Wir haben keine Präsenzpflicht mehr. Zu Zeiten der Präsenzpflicht hatten wir etwa 84% Anwesenheit. Man durfte zweimal fehlen bei 14 Wochen, wenn sie das umrechnen, dann sind das irgendwo um die 85% mussten sie anwesend sein von den 100% Präsenzanteilen. Heute liegt bei uns der Präsenzanteil bei 70%. Mein Ziel ist es, die 84% wieder zu erreichen.
Aber eben ohne, dass es Pflicht ist.
Ohne Druck, es ist keine Pflicht mehr.
Weil auch selbst wenn Leute physisch anwesend sind, sind sie ja unter Umständen geistig abwesend.
Genau. Und es gibt den Trick natürlich, den Kollegen versuchen in der klassischen Lehre, wie kriegen sie Leute in den Hörsaal? In dem sie dauernd erzählen, was ich nächsten Dienstag sage ist klausurrelevant. Die Studierenden hören das Wort Klausur, schon gehen die Lampen an und die Studierenden kommen. Das funktioniert aber nur 3-4 mal, irgendwann wird man unglaubwürdig.
Weil zu viel Löwe gebrüllt wird sozusagen.
Und deswegen sackt die Präsenzphase in den Keller in der heutigen Zeit in klassischen Lehrveranstaltungen. Bei uns hält es sich bei 70%, wir sagen nicht ein einziges mal, es ist klausurrelevant was wir in der Präsenzphase machen. Alles was wir sagen ist, wir bieten euch eine Intensivierung der Inhalte, eine vertiefende Auseinandersetzung mit den Inhalten an. Nicht mehr und nicht weniger.
Eigentlich ist das ja eine Art Hilfsangebot.
Nicht mehr, ja.
So ihr habt eigentlich schon alles geleistet, aber wenn ihr hier seid, dann gibt es einfach einen Grad der interaktiven Auseinandersetzung, der einfach ein Hilfsangebot ist, um letzten Endes die ohnehin irgendwann anstehenden Klausuren dann auch tatsächlich zu schaffen.
Ja und wir untersuchen das seit zwei Jahren auch statistisch mit Auswertungen. Wir ermitteln die Präsenzanwesenheit. Wir lassen die Studierenden unterschreiben, um wirklich diese Daten auch zu bekommen. Und seit zwei Jahren machen wir das und wir haben festgestellt, dass die Studierenden, die in der Präsenzphase da sind, in den Klausuren im Schnitt um 5 Notenpunkte auf der 15er Skala besser abschneiden. Und das ist ein heftiger Wert. Und den teilen wir den Studierenden auch mit. Wir sagen also zu Semesterbeginn, wenn ihr kommt, dann werdet ihr keine Probleme haben, diesen Kurs zu bestehen. Wenn ihr nicht kommt, dann sackt ihr auf der Notenskala ab und das können wir nachweisen. Und ich denke, mehr kann man nicht tun, um diese Präsenzphase attraktiv zu machen, witzig. Mittlerweile gibt es ja auch Dinge wie Gamebased Learning, also dass man spielerisch Dinge macht. Wir machen zum Teil auch Hörsaalspiele für die Studierenden, die natürlich auf hohem Niveau in irgendeiner Form stattfinden.
Gestern zum Beispiel hatte ich eine Lehrveranstaltung, the Evolution of human Language, da mussten die Studierenden eine potenzielle Ursprache für einen Film, einen fiktiven Film, herstellen, der vor 200.000 Jahren stattfand. Das müssen Sie sich mal überlegen, das ist ein hoch anspruchsvolles Thema, und am Ende hatten wir, wir haben in Gruppen gearbeitet, hatten die Gruppen 10 Urwörter der Menschheit erfunden, ganz verschiedene. Und ich habe den anderen gesagt und meinem Team, das ist eine Aufgabe, ich glaube da würden die meisten Hochschulen, die würden in die Knie gehen, die würden überhaupt das gar nicht wagen, so ein Thema zu stellen, weil – das waren Studierende im dritten Semester – weil das so anspruchsvoll ist, weil die gesamte Linguistik dort in dieser Thematik vertreten ist, von der Phonetik bis zur Semantik und das ein hoch intellektueller Anspruch ist, so etwas zu tun.
Was waren denn das für Worte?
Jetzt muss ich überlegen. Wir setzen ja auch Voting-Systeme ein, die mussten das dann über ihr Handy nach vorne geben. Also eins der Urwörter, jetzt von der Bedeutung her, war Fire. Auf Englisch Fire, Feuer. Dann war es Food. Und ein drittes, eines der Hauptwörter war, Danger, Gefahr. Und die phonetischen Entsprechungen, die die entwickelt haben waren so was wie, „Ana“ als eines der Urwörter. Ein anderes war „Ma“ und so haben die dann entsprechende Wörter. Ich kann mich nicht an alle erinnern, die jetzt tatsächlich vorkamen. Es war ein großer Pool von Wortformen, aber die gewissen phonetischen Grundlagen ja auch gehorchen müssen, die man vor 200.000 Jahren ja.
Also nicht so komplexe Lautbildung, wie so „CH“ oder so was, sondern halt so ganz grundlegende.
Und sie mussten halt erkennen, zum einen müssen sie Vokalsysteme kennen, zum anderen müssen sie Konsonantenkomplexitäten erkennen, Silbenstrukturen, sie müssen natürlich auch die kulturellen Hintergründe, die anthropologischen Hintergründe kennen. Die Artikulationsmöglichkeiten der damaligen Menschform, Homo Erectus oder wer auch immer. Also es war eine hochkomplexe Aufgabe, ich war total begeistert, wie die das gelöst haben.
Wenn das Stanley Kubrick mitbekommen hätte.
Na der hätte die sofort verpflichtet und hätte gesagt, den Film machen wir, die Sprache von Team 17 nehmen wir.
Hätte vielleicht nochmal die Szenen von 2001 nachgedreht.
Ja aber was ich damit sagen will ist, es ist eine anspruchsvolle Aufgabe in der Präsenzphase, für die wir a) früher niemals Zeit gehabt hätten, die sich b) in einer individuellen Hausaufgabe gar nicht lösen lässt, weil einem der Input fehlt. Denn ich bin rumgegangen durch die Reihen und habe dann gefragt, warum hat ihr diese Vokale ausgewählt? Warum den Konsonanten? Sollte man nicht vielleicht lieber nachdenken? Und warum das m und nicht das k? Und dann kamen wir in kleine Diskurse hinein mit den Studierenden, auch die Tutoren und haben dann darauf hingewiesen, warum es gewisse Laute sind. Und diese Möglichkeiten haben sie sonst nicht.
Ich würde mal vermuten, dass das auch für Sie persönlich eine sehr viel befriedigendere Lernsituation, also Arbeits- und damit auch Arbeitserfüllungssituation ist oder?
Ja, jetzt sind wir bei den Mehrwerten. Ich hatte ja vor einigen Minuten gesagt, für die Lehrenden entstehen nur sehr geringe Mehrwerte bei der Digitalisierung der Lehre.
Warum?
Ja zunächst einmal ist es Arbeit, Arbeit, Arbeit. Die eigenen Inhalte zu digitalisieren.
Ja gut, aber ob man sich jetzt hinstellt und den Vortrag vor einer Kamera oder vor den Leuten hält, ist ja im Prinzip erst mal dieselbe mentale Leistung.
Ja vor der Kamera ist diese Hürde. Stelle ich mich davor oder nicht?
Ja aber manche rennen ja auch weg, wenn 50 Leute vor einem stehen.
Ja aber manche Leute können ja nicht mal ihre eigene Stimme auf einer digitalen Form ertragen.
Haben Sie eine Theorie, warum das so ist? Ich glaube das ja immer nicht.
Naja weil wir ja die eigene Stimme anders hören durch die Boneconduction heißt es auf englisch, also den Knochenschall.
Ja, aber was macht es so unerträglich? Ist es am Ende nicht doch nur die Angst vor der Öffentlichkeit, die einem dadurch gewahr wird?
Ist möglich ja.
Aber es gibt zumindest keine wissenschaftliche Erkenntnis, warum einem jetzt eine aufgenommene Stimme mehr Angst einflößen sollte. Das wollte ich mal hinterfragen.
Nein, aber wir kennen das ja diesen Effekt, der ist ungewöhnlich. Aber zunächst mal, um nochmal darauf einzugehen, ist erst mal Arbeit. Sie müssten diese digitalen Elemente erst mal erzeugen. Das ist für viele schone ein Hürde, die ist kaum zu überspringen, es sei denn, Sie werden gut beraten. Das ist jetzt so mein Ansatz, individuelle Beratung, zu zeigen das geht, komm das ist nicht so schwierig, und viele Dinge, die man sich vielleicht gar nicht traut zu fragen, sind ganz einfach zu lösen.
Das heißt im Prinzip braucht es auch erst mal in der Lehre auch erst mal ein Coaching der Coaches, um einfach diese Produktion überhaupt durchführen zu können?
Besser kann man es nicht sagen.
Ist das bei Ihnen institutionalisiert schon? Gibt es Leute, die dafür abgestellt sind?
Also ich mache es ja an anderen Hochschulen. Auch individual Coaching, von Professor zu Professor. Und da werden ganz andere Fragen gestellt, als wenn man in einem großen Workshop sitzen würde. Das klappt, das funktioniert, ist natürlich eine Heidenarbeit. Aber das muss gemacht werden. Und wenn man davon ausgeht, dass wahrscheinlich sowieso nicht alle 100% der deutschen Hochschullehrer in die Digitalisierung hineinzubringen sind, vielleicht ich kenne Zahlen, die ja auch der Stifterverband mit in die Welt trägt, dass 50 % sowieso relativ ungeeignet dafür sind und am Ende vielleicht 20% übrig bleiben, die das dann auch machen.
Ungeeignet sind oder glauben, ungeeignet zu sein?
Nein, von denen wir glauben, sie sind ungeeignet. Sie glauben vielleicht, sie sind geeignet, aber möglicherweise sind sie es nicht. Rund 20% von den 40.000 Hochschullehrern, die können wir vielleicht da hineinbringen in die Digitalisierung. Und die müssen wir uns sozusagen individuell vorknöpfen. Und die haben auch Interesse und wenn man das denen richtig, wie in einer Art Schneeballsystem, verbreitet die Digitalisierung, dann werden die es auch schaffen.
Also es ist ein Aufwand, aber es ist zu leisten?
Es ist zu leisten.
Aber trotzdem mag es erst mal dem Lehrenden sehr vorkommen wie eine zusätzliche neue ungewohnte und unerwartete Belastung, auch auf einmal so arbeiten zu sollen, wo man es doch auch hätte so machen können, wie sonst immer auch und da sind ja auch alle zufrieden.
Genau. Also wie gesagt, es erschließt sich so auf den ersten Blick überhaupt kein Mehrwert, sondern nur erst mal nur ein Minderwert, der da heißt, viel viel Arbeit. Aber wenn man dann so ein gewisses MAß an Digitalisierung erreicht hat, nehmen wir mal an, Sie haben ein kleines Video erzeugt zu einem Inhalt, der Sie in der Präsenzphase vielleicht 5 Minuten kostet. Das kann ein begriff sein, den man in der Jura zu erklären hat. Das kann eine Grafik sein über die Koronargefäße in der Medizin. Das kann eine architektonische Sache sein in einem Architekturstudium oder eine Landkarte. Und wenn Sie das dann digitalisiert haben und sich selber fragen, was mache ich denn jetzt eigentlich in der Präsenzphase, wo ich das doch nun digital habe. Und dann kommen Sie sehr schnell zur Antwort, ach da habe ich eigentlich 10 Minuten gewonnen. Sie können früher nach Hause gehen.
Können sagen, okay dann beträgt meine Vorlesung nur 80 Minuten. Kann man machen. Man kann aber auch ein Blatt mitbringen und sagen, ich habe hier eine kleine Aufgabe für euch. Und schon sind Sie in ein, ich nenne es mal, teilinvertierten Szenario gekommen, und merken plötzlich, oh ich gewinne gewisse Freiräume in der Lehre. Und wenn Sie das immer weiter treiben, dann kommen wir zu dem Effekt, den Sie angesprochen haben, nämlich die Lehrzufriedenheit. Und die Lehrzufriedenheit bei mir, die ist heute so ungleich höher als sie noch vor einigen Jahren war. Was auch hinzukommt ist die physikalische Erschöpfung, die ist auch da. Ich bin eigentlich immer ziemlich platt nach 90 Minuten.
Weil es so interaktiv ist?
Ja, weil es ist auf der einen Seite physikalisch anstrengend, man rennt hin und her. Dann ist man hinten, dann ruft einer vorne. Dann muss man plötzlich mal wieder nach vorne, eine kurze Zusammenfassung liefern, weil man merkt, es geht nicht weiter. Es gibt zwar Fernsteuerungsmöglichkeiten des zentralen Computers vom Publikum aus, aber die sind noch sehr wackelig, weil die WLAN-Verbindungen nicht überall so stabil sind, dass man das machen könnte. Ich habe es auch schon versucht, das klappt so ein bisschen, aber man muss sich viel bewegen. Man muss viel in die Knie gehen, um auf Augenhöhe zu kommen. Und vor allen Dingen, man wird mit Fragen bombardiert, die weit über die Inhalte hinausgehen. Die wirklich weit über die Inhalte der Lehrveranstaltung hinausgehen. Das sind Fragen zum Beispiel wie, Herr Hanke gestern hat der Kollege Meier gesagt, das wäre so und so, können Sie uns das nochmal erklären?
Dann sage ich, das ist doch gar nicht meine Aufgabe, aber gut wir versuchen es mal. Und dann haben Sie plötzlich ganz andere Themen dabei, die die Studierenden sonst niemals aufs Tableau bringen würden, weil sie ja frontal einfach nur berieselt werden. Und das macht mich sehr zufrieden. Ich habe immer gesagt, ich war ja früher mal Musiker, Ziel meiner Lehre ist es, das zu erreichen, was ich als Musiker erreicht habe, nämlich dass die Leute freiwillig klatschen und nicht auf den Tischen klopfen, weil sie es immer machen. Sie sollen klopfen, wenn sie es gut finden, sie sollen auch nicht klopfen, wenn sie es nicht gut finden.
Ich habe so selber auch, wenn ich in so Unterrichtssituationen bin, festgestellt, dass umso interaktiver das abläuft, man eigentlich auch selber sein eigenes Thema sehr viel besser verstehen lernt und eigentlich überhaupt erst beginnt, richtig zu begreifen, umso mehr man eben Rückmeldung auch bekommt und Momente hat, in denen man feststellt, warum jemand anderes etwas nicht versteht. Ich könnte mir jetzt vorstellen, dass mit dieser hohen Interaktivität und dem hohen Potenzial an Nachfragen, dass es auch zum eigenen Verständnis der Materie, beziehungsweise eigenen Verständnis der Lehrmethodik auch ein sehr interessanter Rückfluss ist, in so einer Art von Präsenzveranstaltung zu sein.
Und der Materialien. Wir haben festgestellt, dass einige der Materialien, von denen wir dachten, sie seien sehr gut geeignet zum Üben, sich überhaupt nicht eignen. Weil Zwischenschritte der Informationen fehlen, weil sie einfach viel zu einfach dargestellt wurden. So wie man es aus Büchern kennt, da ist eine Aufgabe gestellt und es gibt kaum Erklärungen dazu, welche Lösungsansätze man für die Aufgabe entwickeln kann. Also wir überarbeiten quasi nach jedem Semester, nach einem kompletten Durchlauf, unsere Präsenzmaterialien, weil wir feststellen, da gibt es Dinge, die eignen sich besonders gut, dann gibt es Dinge, die eignen ich gar nicht, weil sie einfach vom Ansatz her in die völlig falsche Richtung gingen.
Fehlerhaft, natürlich haben unsere Materialien Fehler. Also wer glaubt, dass der Virtual Linguistic Campus fehlerfrei sei, bei geschätzten 250.000 Webseiten und vielen Elementen, also das geht gar nicht.
Oder auch fehlerhaft sind.
Aber er verbessert sich laufend?
Laufend. Also wir kriegen auch immer Rückmeldung über kleinste Vertipper. Und dadurch, dass wir selber die Plattform ja hier behandeln, können wir die auch sehr schnell dann beheben diese Dinge.
Das bringt uns so ein bisschen auch zu den Werkzeugen und ich fang vielleicht nochmal mit der digitalen Plattform, mit der Webseite an. Das ist ja sehr ungewöhnlich, dass Software quasi selbst entwickelt wird in einer Universität, auch in Unternehmen. Häufig nimmt man ja irgendwas, was schon da ist. Es gibt ja auch so verschiedene OpenSource-Systeme, die so in der Education gerne eingesetzt werden, Moodle und ähnliche Systeme. Aber Sie haben sich ja von Vornherein für etwas eigenes entschieden?
Ja wir mussten, weil es gab noch nichts anderes.
Weil es nichts gab, okay gut, das ist natürlich dann immer der beste Grund. Aber letztlich haben Sie es auch nicht bereut? Es ist jetzt nicht so, dass Sie sagen würden, ach wir mussten alles selber machen und wenn ich da die Möglichkeit gehabt hätte, dann hätte ich das lieber nicht gemacht?
Ja es gab mal Bestrebungen auch an unserer Hochschule, zu sagen, der Virtual Linguistic Campus müsste in Ilias integriert werden. Das ist unsere Hochschulplattform. Wir haben dann einen Kostenvoranschlag gemacht und der hat uns einfach abgeschreckt, das wäre viel zu aufwendig gewesen. Und Ilias hätte sich massiv ändern müssen, um die Dinge tun zu können, die wir tun und wir hätten uns massiv ändern müssen, um das zu tun, was Ilias macht. Und es wäre nicht mehr so gewesen wie vorher. Wir haben dann die Finger davon gelassen. Es wäre natürlich toll, wenn wir offene Tools verwenden könnten, aber die können leider nicht das leisten, was wir so im Laufe der Jahre uns so zusammengestückelt haben. Das ist so ähnlich wie die Europäische Union verwendet ein Übersetzungssystem namens Systran, das wurde 1962 erstmalig entwickelt. Es wurde immer wieder was drangesetzt, drangesetzt, drangesetzt, irgendwann kam man nicht mehr davon weg.
Heute würde man vielleicht sogar mit Google-Translate gewisse Dinge übersetzen können, aber irgendwann kommt man nicht mehr raus aus der Nummer. Das ist bei uns auch so, wir kommen einfach nicht mehr raus, es sei denn, man gibt uns Geld in die Hand und sagt, hier habt ihr zwei Jahre Zeit und nun überlegt euch andere Wege.
Würden Sie das dann auch machen? Also ist jetzt der Druck schon so groß, dass man das eigentlich schon alles mal wieder neu machen wollen würde, weil die Basis zu alt ist?
Naja es wäre vielleicht insofern ganz gut, als man überlegen könnte, irgendwann wird der Hanke und sein Team ja mal nicht mehr existieren. Pensionierung, Auseinanderfallen. Das es dann OpenSource-mäßig orientiert werden könnte, was es jetzt ja nicht ist. Das wäre eine Überlegung wert. Was passiert eigentlich danach? Noch haben wir ja hier ein paar Jahre zusammen, aber irgendwann …
... das wäre ja dann auch der ideale Ausklang auch, dass man dann sozusagen über sein Vermächtnis sich darauf konzentriert und sagt, okay lehren könnt ihr selber, weil ich habe ja schon alles auf Video aufgenommen, mich bedarf es ja eigentlich ... also Sie haben sich ja im Prinzip auch, ich sage nicht abgeschafft, aber im Prinzip entbehrlicher gemacht, was für Sie ja in gewisser Hinsicht auch eine Befreiung sein kann, weil Sie sich ja im Prinzip ja dann auch auf so eine Tätigkeiten konzentrieren können, ohne dass die eigentliche Lehre darunter leidet und ohne dass man sich jetzt auch gleich einen neuen Professor suchen muss. Ich finde das trotzdem sehr interessant, weil ich auch selber die Erfahrung gemacht habe, Software, die von den Leuten erstellt wird, die sie auch selber benutzen, ganz andere Qualitäten hat in der Regel, tausend mal besser funktioniert, als alles was irgendwie von der Stange kommt und was so den Versuch dann macht, in die Breite zu gehen. Weil natürlich Software nur dann erfolgreich ist, wenn sie sich halt entweder sehr teuer verkauft wird oder sehr viel verkauft. Deswegen versucht man, es irgendwie jedem Recht zu machen, aber bei dem Versuch, es jedem Recht zu mache, macht man es halt eben eigentlich gar keinem mehr so Recht.
Und es steckt ja dann auch sehr Erfahrung drin in den Prozessen. Das Beispiel mit der Dynamic Multiple Choice, was dann sozusagen ja auch so eine Erfindung ist, in gewisser Hinsicht aus der Not geboren, ja am Ende aber auch sagt, ja okay, das war dann aber auch mal wirklich ein super Ansatz und das können wir als Lehrmittel empfehlen und wir haben das sozusagen nicht nur als abstrakte Idee geschaffen, sondern wir haben es auch konkret in Code gegossen und hier wenn man das genauso vom Userinterface-Ablauf her, vom Prozedere her macht und auch von der statistischen Auswertung, dann erfüllt es eben auch wirklich alle Ziele und funktioniert gut. Um vielleicht nochmal auch so einen Blick … - also jetzt ist es natürlich schwer, einem beliebigen anderen Lehrstuhl erst mal so zu kommen mit, also erstes müsst ihr euch eure eigene Software bauen. Obwohl das ja in gewisser Hinsicht, ich habe es ja gerade gesagt, auch zu empfehlen wäre. Nur dass es natürlich nicht jeder selber machen kann.
Worauf ich hinaus will ist, wäre es nicht sehr angeraten, grundsätzlich nach Modellen zu suchen, wie ein Lehrstuhl auch seine eigene Software entwickeln lassen kann? Also dass man quasi sagt, so wie wir hier ein Sekretariat haben und Leute, die sich um die Gebäudereinigung kümmern, braucht eigentlich die Universität auch lehrstuhlbezogen, institutbezogen, auf welcher Ebene man das auch immer aufhängt, quasi ein Softwareentwicklungsteam oder man braucht technische Wissenschaftler, die quasi an der Stelle wirken?
Also ich glaube das nicht. Ich glaube, jetzt mal abgesehen von der Entwicklung einer Plattform mit Benutzerdaten und mit Authentifizierungsdingen und Urkundengenerierung, das sind natürlich Spezialaufgaben, die sehr komplex sind, da gehören erhebliche Programmierkenntnisse dazu, Datenbanken im Hintergrund. Ich glaube mal, wenn man das mal nicht betrachtet, sollten die Grundlagen zum Beispiel für die Digitalisierung von Lehre und Lerninhalten, Videoerstellung, Erstellung einfacher Webseiten mit Kontaktformularen, die Nutzung der sozialen Netzwerke, die bei uns auch eine große Rolle spielen. Alle unsere Lehrveranstaltungen sind mit Facebook-Gruppen vernetzt. Das sollte doch eigentlich heute zum Standardrepertoire eines Lehrenden gehören. Vor 30 Jahren war die Medienkompetenz begrenzt darauf, dass man Kreide in der Hand halten konnte und dass man die drei Schalterstellungen eines Overhead-Projektors bedienen konnte.
Das ist heute nun mal mehr geworden. Und das muss ein Lehrender einfach, sonst eignet er sich nicht zum Lehrenden, das muss er einfach können. Mit der Plattform würde ich sagen, das ist ein Schritt zu weit, wir haben ja hier auch Kurse bei uns, die wir selber betreuen, neue Medien im Fremdsprachenunterricht zum Beispiel. Medienproduktion für Lehrkräfte. Da empfehlen wir einfach, nehmt doch Dinge wie Weebly oder WordPress, damit könnt ihr hervorragende Webseiten erstellen und könnt Video integrieren. Ihr könnt alles machen was ihr wollt, nur ihr habt keine Benutzerverwaltung da drin. Und wenn man dieses Thema Benutzerverwaltung vielleicht außen vor lässt, dann müsste eigentlich jeder in der Lage sein, mit einem kleinen bisschen technischen Knowhow und mit einer geringen Ausbildung vielleicht, einer zusätzlichen Ausbildung, das zu schaffen.
Zumindest erst mal eine Verbesserung.
Wobei so ein integrierter Ansatz, ich finde den ja eigentlich ganz charmant.
Ja genau.
Ja aber wenn ich sehe, was wir so im Laufe der Jahre programmiert haben, von Passwortschutz und die Authentifizierung und nehmen Sie allein, jede Woche vergessen 5 Studierende ihr Passwort, das ist so Standard. Jetzt kann man natürlich nachgucken in der Datenbank und denen das sagen, aber es wäre doch besser und das haben wir dann entwickelt, eine automatische Passwortwiederherstellung, die ja bei Amazon und überall existiert, aber wir mussten sie entwickeln.
Ja gut, ich meine das ist natürlich, deswegen meinte ich ja auch gerade, vielleicht wäre das ja auch mal eine Aufgabe für die Informatik. Ich meine, dass es Spezialisierung gibt wie Bioinformatik und andere Formen, das ist bekannt, aber wo ist die pädagogische Informatik. Wo ist sozusagen die Spezialisierung auf das Lehren mit digitalen Medien, weil dass das jetzt weniger wird, das ist ja nun auch nicht gerade abzusehen. Wir sitzen ja jetzt hier auch gerade in Ihrem Büro. Ein Büro, was so ein bisschen den Eindruck macht, als ob hier der neue YouTube-Star am Start ist. In gewisser Hinsicht sind Sie das ja auch. Greenscreen, große Lampen, Kameras, also im Prinzip ist Ihr Büroumfeld ein Studio, kann man sagen?
Mittlerweile.
Mit verschiedensten Kameraoptionen und Möglichkeiten, hier Kontent zu generieren. Wie würden Sie denn den ... weil das ist ja auch immer so ein Argument dieser ganzen Debatte, das wäre ja alles sehr teuer. Ist das so? Oder rechnet man das falsch? Was für einen Aufwand man da betreiben müsste.
Zum Nulltarif gibt es das ja nicht. Also es muss beschafft werden. Allerdings kann ich sagen, ich habe dafür so gut wie nichts bezahlt, weil ich es irgendwie geschafft habe, über Sponsoren und Spenden mir diese Materialien ohne Unterstützung von außen zusammenzustellen. Und ich denke, mit ein bisschen innovativen Ideen können das auch andere Hochschullehrer schaffen. Also ich setze eine Software ein, die Softwarefirma unterstützt mich. Ich setze ein interaktives Whitboard ein und die interaktive Whiteboardfirma, die Herstellerfirma unterstützt mich. Dafür trage ich auch schon mal ein T-Shirt, wo der Aufdruck der jeweiligen Firma im Video zu sehen ist. Und auch im Video selbst prankt das Logo dieser Firma im Abspann mit drin. Ob der Abspann gesehen wird weiß ich nicht. Es ist nie vorher. Also wir würden niemals einem wissenschaftlichen Video eine Nutella-Werbung voranschalten. Das kommt für uns nicht in Frage.
Also keine Werbung in wissenschaftlichen Videos. Aber man kann glaube ich, indem man die Firmen promoted, indem man ihnen Angebote macht, indem man sagt, ich bin demnächst an der Universität sowieso, schickt bitte eure Prospekte schon mal dahin, wenn ich dann komme und dann sage ich auch ein paar Worte dazu. Dann kann man von den Firmen auch Unterstützung bekommen, so dass das für beide Seiten eine win-win-Situation ist.
Aber schöner wäre es ja eigentlich, wenn man ein bisschen aussuchen könnte oder?
Ja es wäre schöner, wenn die Hochschulen Geld in die Hand nehmen würden oder auch die Politik und das ist nun leider im Bereich Lehre nicht so. Es wird ja immer nur der Bereich Forschung gesehen, da fließen die Millionen und im Bereich Lehre da ist man mit wesentlich geringeren Beträgen am Start.
Wodurch kommt das, dass die Lehre gegenüber der Forschung derzeit so einen schlechten Stand hat?
Ich glaube viele, ich sage es jetzt ganz bewusst, der Professorinnen und Professoren sehen sich nicht als Hochschullehrer, obwohl ihre Berufsbezeichnung Hochschullehrer ist. Zumindest schreiben wir das in unsere Steuererklärung hinein. Die sehen sich gar nicht so. Die sehen sich eben als Forscher und Forscherinnen. Dadurch kann man mehr, .. das ist ja auch die Währung der Karriere sozusagen.
Aber Sie sehen sich doch auch als Forscher, oder als was sehen Sie sich?
Ja ich bin mittlerweile eine Art Bildungsforscher geworden, was eigentlich gar nicht mein Ziel war. Ich bin da so reingerutscht. Und eigentlich hätte ich ja jetzt über Psycholinguistik, Phonetik oder irgendwas forschen müssen und dort meine Ergebnisse publizieren und wäre dann auf Fachtagungen vielleicht ein berühmter Linguist geworden. Wobei Berühmtheit in solch kleinen Kreisen mit Vorsicht zu betrachten ist. Also Chomsky ist berühmt, Sie haben ihn erwähnt, sonst glaube ich ist kein einziger Linguist in der Welt wirklich richtig berühmt.
Am MIT gab es noch ein paar sehr einflussreiche.
Ja es gibt noch welche, ich will jetzt niemandem zu nahe treten. Aber so richtig berühmt wird man als Linguist nicht notwendigerweise. Und mittlerweile muss ich sagen, kennen mich wahrscheinlich viel mehr Leute, als mich in der Linguistik jemals Leute hätten kennenlernen können, weil ich ja fächerübergreifend jetzt tätig bin. Aber in die Forschung wird halt deswegen ja von Anfang an gefördert, weil das ja die Eintrittskarten in die Karriere sind. Dissertation, Habilitation. Habilitation hat ja mit Lehre nicht viel zu tun, das ist ja eine zweite Forschungsarbeit. Und wenn Sie sich heute um eine Professorenstelle bewerben, dann ist ja die Forschungsleistung im Vordergrund. Dann werden Gutachten eingeholt worüber? Über die Publikationen. Es guckt ja keiner und stellt sich rein in den Hörsaal und sagt, wie lehrt dieser Mensch eigentlich? Und der Habilitationsvortrag, um die Venia Legendi zu bekommen, der ist ja ein schlechter Witz. Das ist ein Forschungsvortrag.
Es gibt Bestrebungen, ich will jetzt einigen Hochschulen nicht zu nahe treten, also ich kenne einige, die machen das sehr gut und die haben auch didaktische Begleitszenarien für die Habilitation, aber das sind viel zu wenige, die das machen. In vielen ist noch die klassische Forschungsleistung, die steht im Vordergrund und die Lehre wird eigentlich kaum wertgeschätzt. Schauen Sie sich mal die Homepages der deutschen Hochschulen an, welche Homepage enthält ein Link zur Lehre. Zur Forschung alle. Alle Hochschulen sprechen immer von Forschung und Lehre, aber einen Link zur Lehre haben sie nicht. Also ich habe mal ganz viele angeguckt, das können Sie an zwei Händen abzählen, die Hochschulen, die wirklich einen Link zur Lehre haben auf ihrer Homepage.
Weil das einfach so einen schlechten ...?
Ja man kann mit Lehre nicht punkten. Wenn ein Hochschullehrer sagt, ich befass mich jetzt nur damit, dass meine Lehre besser wird, dann leidet ... er oder sie kann sich ja auch nicht teilen ... dann leidet sein Zeitkontingent darunter, man hat halt nur, jetzt mal im klassischen Fall, eine 41 Stunden Woche. Es gibt Untersuchungen, dass Professoren gesagt haben, bis zu 60 Stunden arbeiten sie pro Woche. Aber selbst dann, wenn Sie das prozentual runter brechen, reicht es einfach nicht.
Trotzdem es ändert sich ja was und gerade die starke Onlineaktivität, kennt man ja aus den USA, vor allem von den großen und finanziell auch ganz anders ausgestatteten privaten Universitäten, den Big, wie viele sind das, diese 10-11 da. Ja genau, dieser Verein der wohlhabenden Universitäten. Aber die haben ja im Prinzip ja schon vor einigen Jahren angefangen, große Teile ihrer Vorlesungen mit Video zu erfassen, auch öffentlich zu publizieren. Ich weiß nicht, ob Ihre Vorträge in dem Sinne auch öffentlich verfügbar sind?
Ja auch im YouTube-Kanal, im gleichen Kanal.
Im Prinzip alles, was hier quasi als Wissensmaterial bereitgestellt wird, das kriegt man jetzt nicht nur über die Campus-Software, sondern liegt ohnehin rum. Also wenn ich sozusagen ein Linguistik-Studium beginnen möchte, könnte ich im Prinzip direkt auf YouTube damit anfangen. Ich habe nur nicht den Vorteil, hier in diesen weiteren Bearbeitungsprozess aufgenommen zu werden.
Sie kriegen es nicht zertifiziert.
Genau, ich kriege es nicht zertifiziert, aber zumindest könnte ich mir das Wissen aneignen, das finde ich auch mal eine super Sache. Ich sehe da schon einen Trend und in gewisser Hinsicht auch eine Notwendigkeit, aber wie bewerten Sie denn das, wie es da jetzt vorangehen wird?
Ja so erst mal noch ein Wort zu diesen YouTube-Aktivitäten einiger in Deutschland. Das bin ja nicht nur ich. Es gibt ja noch andere, im Bereich Mathematik, Informatik ist das noch viel populärer. Die Frage immer, warum machen die das, die wird einem ja immer gestellt. Und das ist übrigens ein Mehrwert, den wir erringen, den wir sonst nie bekommen würden, nämlich Lob. Sie bekommen ja in der klassischen Lehre nicht von den Kollegen gesagt, Mensch Hanke Sie kommen gerade aus dem Hörsaal, ich habe gehört, das soll gut gewesen sein. Macht ja keiner.
Echt nicht? Schade.
Nein, es kommt keiner vorbei und sagt, toll gelehrt. Den Studierenden ist es eigentlich auch egal, die wollen nur ihre Credit-Points und das bleibt dann immer unter Verschluss. Und plötzlich kriegen Sie im YouTube-Kanal Lob aus der ganzen Welt. Tolle e-Lecture, ich habe gelernt, ich habe gestern meine Prüfung bestanden, Sie haben mir sehr geholfen. Und tausende, zigtausende Kommentare, die Sie einfach umhauen. Und ich weiß von den Kollegen, die ähnliches auf YouTube oder anderen öffentlichen Szenarien machen, die sind auch sehr sehr angetan von dieser Art von Lobpreisung, die sie sonst nie erfahren würden. Also das ist wirklich ein Mehrwert, auf den sind wir sehr sehr stolz. Wie es weitergeht im Bereich der Digitalisierung. Also Sie sprechen vielleicht auch das Hochschulforum Digitalisierung an, das ja eine ganz tolle Einrichtung ist aus meiner Sicht, das zu einer unglaublichen Vernetzung in Deutschland geführt hat, von Akteuren, die trotz unterschiedlichen Dienststandes vom Unipräsidenten bis zum kleinen Mitarbeiter auf Augenhöhe über die Digitalisierung reden. Also ich finde das eine ganz tolle Sache.
Man hat sich kennengelernt, man weiß plötzlich, was in Freiburg, in München, in Flensburg, in Stralsund vor sich geht, nein Stralsund nicht, aber in .. ja doch. Und man kennt die Szenerie, und das hat zu einer Vernetzung geführt, die jetzt überall Aktivitäten sichtbar macht und bei denen wir uns unterhalten können, was macht ihr, wo habt ihr Probleme? Wir haben gemerkt, bei uns funktioniert das nicht und so weiter. Und das ist glaube ich ein erster Ansatz, der einfach fantastisch ist. Wir haben neue Ideen entwickelt gemeinsam. Auch entwickelt im Bereich des Hochschulbaus, der Architekturen. Denn, wenn Sie zum Beispiel so was nehmen wie den Inverted Classroom, die klassische Sitzreihenarchitektur funktioniert nicht mehr gut in einer solchen Präsenzphase. Da wären Lerninseln viel hilfreicher und das geht mittlerweile in die Hochschulen hinein.
Und die überlegen in der Tat, es gibt Hochschulen, die Hochschule Coburg, die beginnt ab 2017 mit Neubauten, die so strukturiert werden. Oder in Österreich, Fachhochschule Krems, Smartworking nennt man das. Also überall gibt es kleine Pflänzchen, die sich entwickeln. Mittlerweile die Präsidien werden aufmerksam auf diese, ... wie nennt das Hochschulforum Digitalisierung diese ... diese Subsysteme. Also wir sind hier ein Subsystem. Und dass diese Subsysteme immer weiter nach oben kommen, immer mehr angezapft werden. Ich selbst kriege Anfragen. Da kann jetzt natürlich auch der Preis eine Rolle spielen, wir wollen ein Mooc entwickeln, können Sie uns helfen, haben Sie vielleicht Ideen, was wir tun können?
Massive online Courses.
Genau. Und so gibt es ja ganz viele, die in dem Hochschulforum Digitalisierung ähnlich unterwegs sind wie ich und die man einfach fragt, die man um Rat bittet und ich glaube, das ist eine ganz tolle Sache. Und das glaube ich jetzt der Ansatzpunkt und da können wir dem Stifterverband, der Hochschulrektorenkonferenz, BMWF und CHE nur danken, dass sie das geschafft haben, gemeinsam eben aufs Gleis zu stellen.
Sie sagten ja vorhin, 50% der Professoren, so aus Ihrer Sichtweise.
Das stammt nicht von mir. Das wurde 2013 auf der auch vom Stifterverband organisierten Tagung „MOOCs and beyond“ wurde das ins Publikum gesagt. 50% der Lehrenden werden wir sowieso sozusagen abschreiben können.
Na gut, aber mal salopp formuliert, die sterben ja dann in gewisser Hinsicht auch irgendwann aus. Die Frage ist, wie positioniert sich der Nachwuchs? Welches Selbstverständnis braucht man, wenn man sich jetzt entweder als Quereinsteiger oder auch mit einer bewussten Ausbildung sich quasi für die Lehre auch in Stellung bringt? Was muss in der Pädagogik quasi noch zusätzlich vermittelt werden? Welche Weichen müssten jetzt gestellt werden, um die neue Form des Lehrens, wie Sie sie propagieren, zu berücksichtigen?
Sie sprechen die Pädagogik an. Das ist sowieso eine etwas heikle Geschichte. Diese neuen Formen des Lehrens. Ob das Inverted Classroom ist, ob das Digitalisierung, Gamebased Learning, Learner Analytics, all das was man da so verwendet an Begriffen, kommt ja interessanterweise nicht aus der Pädagogik, sondern kommt aus interessierten Fachwissenschaftlern. Ich hatte es schon gesagt, Mathematiker, Informatiker, Mediziner, wir Linguisten. Die Pädagogik hat erstaunlicherweise in den vergangenen Jahren recht wenig zu diesen Themen gesagt. Und möglicherweise müssen die sich erst mal selbst auf neu positionieren, um in diesen Bereichen tätig zu werden. Alle Entwicklungen kommen aus Fachwissenschaften oder sie kommen aus den USA oben drüber gestülpt. Die Mooc-Bewegung stammt von einem Menschen, Sebastian Thrun, Artificial Intelligence, ein Informatiker. Und die Pädagogen haben eigentlich nie was dazu zu sagen gehabt zu diesem Thema.
Also das heißt, das ist auch etwas was ich propagiere, die Hochschule müssen ihre didaktischen Einheiten, die sie ja haben, didaktische Kompetenzteams, wie immer man die nennt, die müssen sie erst mal selber in diesen Bereich Digitalisierung hineinführen. Und das passiert an einigen Hochschulen, das weiß ich, ich war auch dort, die kann ich auch lobend sogar erwähnen, Uni Würzburg ein ganz tolles Beispiel, die positionieren sich da jetzt gerade in dem Bereich. Technische Universität München, ganz toll was die da machen. Aber andere eben sind noch nicht so weit. Und die müssen ihre Didaktikteams erst mal entsprechend neu ausrichten.
Was ist das mit den Schulen? Im Prinzip, vieles von dem, was Sie jetzt hier über die Arbeit mit den Studenten gesagt haben, wenn ich mich so in meine Schulzeit zurückversetze, dann denke ich mir so, hätte ich da eigentlich auch schon ganz gut anwenden können. Ich meine, gut es gab kein Internet, da war an Digitalvideo noch nicht zu denken, aber heute ist das ja anders. Und all die Möglichkeiten, die Sie hier mit Ihren Studenten durchziehen, könnte man ja im Prinzip auch in der Schule genauso machen?
Macht man ja auch.
Spricht da was gegen?
Nein, überhaupt nicht, ja doch eins, das Handyverbot. Das ist ein großes Problem.
Das spricht dagegen, das so zu machen, weil das Handyverbot eine gute Sache ist oder?
Nein, weil die Schüler natürlich das Handy nicht benutzen dürfen, ist eine große Hürde.
Na gut, aber das könnte man ja ändern.
Das würde ich auch hoffen, dass das getan wird. Aber was eben gemacht wird ist eben ein Inverted Classroom Szenario, das man auf schulischer Ebene Flipped Classroom nennt. Das ist etwas einfacher, weil ja auch die Rhythmen anders sind. Das ist ein Tagesrhythmus, da kann man nicht groß noch diese Tests dazwischen schalten. Es ist ein einfacheres Szenario, aber es gibt ganz viele Lehrer mittlerweile, eine Lehrerin auch, eine Chemikerin aus Koblenz, die immer mehr in diesen Bereich hineindringen, die ihre eigenen Lehrvideos produzieren. Kleine Lehrvideos 5 Minuten zum Passiv im Englischen, zum Dreisatz in der Mathematik, zu einem chemischen Versuchsaufbau. Die sprießen überall in ganz Deutschland aus dem Boden. Und dieser Flipped Classroom an den Schulen wird immer populärer. Kommt auch aus den USA rübergeschwappt. Und mehr und mehr Schülerinnen und Schüler bereiten sich über ihre Handys auf den Unterricht vor und üben dort entsprechend mit den Lehrkräften.
Aber bei der Schule ist es ja normalerweise so, dass wenn man erst mal aus der Schule raus ist, dass dann Schule auch abgestellt ist. Also dieses Nachbereiten, Vorbereiten, selbst erarbeiten ist ja gar nicht so sehr Teil der Schularbeit bisher?
Wenn Sie jetzt meinen den Übergang zur Hochschule.
Nein, jetzt einfach nur wenn ich mir das so vorstelle, dieses Dreifaltigkeitsmodell der Wissensvermittlung, der Tests und der Prüfungen, wenn ich das sozusagen so übertragen würde, das würde ja eine ganz andere Einbeziehung der Zeit, die heute noch Freizeit ist, voraussetzen.
Ja aber viele Schüler haben das erkannt. Ich kann ein Beispiel von meinem Sohn, der hat vor kurzem Abitur gemacht, berichten. Der hat fast seine ganze Abiturvorbereitung über Lehrvideos gemacht. Und auf YouTube hat der alle Beispiele gefunden, die er brauchte und hat mit tollen Zensuren abgeschnitten. Das ist heute Gang und Gäbe. Und das Problem ist, die Lehrer wissen das zum Teil ja gar nicht, dass es diese tollen Materialien gibt. Und die stellen sich dann in antiquierter Weise vor die Schüler, übrigens genau auch wie viele Hochschullehrer, die keine Ahnung davon haben, dass es irgendwo Kurse gibt zu den Themen, die sie selbst machen und diese Kurse sind frei und offen, Moocs, da sind wir wieder bei diesem Thema. Und dann stellen die sich in den Hörsaal oder in den Klassenraum und unterrichten etwas in antiquierter Weise etwas, was die Schüler oder die Studierenden schon längst wissen. Kein Wunder, dass die dann keine Lust mehr haben, in die Präsenzphase zu kommen.
In der Schule sitzen sie gelangweilt rum, weil sie müssen. In der Hochschule gehen sie gar nicht erst mehr hin. Und das ist nämlich die zukünftige Entwicklung, die stattfinden wird, wenn wir nicht aufpassen, wenn wir nicht kluge Präsenzphasenkonzepte entwickeln, die die Schülerinnen und Schüler und Studentinnen und Studenten wieder zu uns bringen.
Das heißt auch der Schulunterricht könnte sich also genauso eigentlich auch in so ein coachingorientiertes der Lehrer als, ich sag mal, als Freund sozusagen als unmittelbarer…
Als Begleiter.
Begleiter genau der Tätigkeit und des interaktiven Erarbeitens. Was ja dann auch den Nebeneffekt haben dürfte, dass man auch sehr viel mehr auf die individuellen Unterschiede der Lehrleistung eingehen kann.
Genau, das ist ja genau der Punkt, Individualisierung ganz wichtiges Thema in der heutigen Lehre, ob Schule oder Hochschule und neue Freiräume auch den Lernenden zu geben, immer unter der Voraussetzung natürlich, dass sie diese Freiräume auch vernünftig zu nutzen verstehen. Übrigens ein kleines Problem auch, viele der Studierenden, die bei uns in diesen digitalisierten Kursen sind, denen müssen wir auch diesen Freiraum, diese Nutzung des Freiraums in gewisser Weise beibringen, denn es ist gar nicht so einfach zu sagen, nun ja ob ich nun diese Lerneinheit Montag, Dienstag oder Mittwoch, Mittwochabend habe ich noch eine Fete, ach machen wir es Donnerstag, ach wieder was dazwischen gekommen und schwupps ist der Präsenztermin da und man hat nichts gemacht, weil man es ja zeitlich sehr flexibel tun konnte. Und das ist ein Problem, das haben wir auch erkannt, das muss auch den Studierenden mitgeteilt werden. Deswegen habe ich beim Hochschulforum Digitalisierung auch angeregt, auch Handlungsempfehlungen für Studierende zu entwickeln. Nicht nur für die Hochschulen und die Politik, sondern auch für die Studierenden. Denn deren Lage ändert sich ja auch.
Was könnte so eine Handlungsempfehlung sein?
Na da muss eben drin stehen, wie geht man mit Freiräumen um? Welche Medienkompetenz brauche ich als Studierender, um zum Beispiel mit digitalen Lehrformaten in irgendeiner Form klarzukommen. Ich kann und will da gar nicht vorgreifen, ich habe es nur angeregt, das wird Teil meiner Arbeitsgruppe in den nächsten Monaten sein, diese Handlungsempfehlungen, wir sind ja dran, für die Lehre zu erarbeiten.
Zum Abschluss vielleicht, was müsste sich denn die Bildungspolitik, zum Beispiel die Hochschulpolitik jetzt noch so ein bisschen auf die ToDo-Lists schreiben, um solche Prozesse besser begleiten und unterstützen zu können? Wo mangelt es denn?
Also es gibt zwei Punkte, die ja in der Öffentlichkeit eine große Rolle spielen. Der eine ist der Begriff, Open Educational Ressources. Man möchte ja, das ist ja das deutsche Bildungsprinzip, diese Materialien kostenlos zur Verfügung stellen. Kostenlos ja, aber sie fallen nicht vom Himmel, sie müssen erzeugt werden und die Erzeugung kostet Geld. Und ich glaube aber, das ist der Politik auch klar. Ich höre da Stimmen aus dem Bundestag, die das auch sehr genau wissen. Natürlich muss das dann auf die Länder verteilt werden. Wobei eine Sache, die vielleicht auch ganz wichtig ist, der Föderalismus ist für die Digitalisierung eigentlich nicht mehr das Modell, was wir brauchen, denn es betrifft ganz Deutschland. Und wenn immer die Ländergrenzen wieder dazwischen sind und alles 16 mal erfunden werden muss ist das eher hinderlich. Aber Open Educational Ressources kosten Geld und das muss man in die Hand nehmen.
Aber bietet ja auch hier wieder ein bisschen das Versprechen, hat man erst mal alles digitalisiert kann man sich ab einem bestimmten Zeitpunkt einfach nur noch um die Verbesserung kümmern, man muss nicht immer wieder alles von vorne erzählen lassen.
Genau, aber der Startschuss ist erst mal mit Kosten verbunden. Und für viele ist es ja ein Startschuss. Auf der anderen Seite kann man natürlich auch Gremien schaffen. Ich weiß, dass das in einigen Bundesländern mittlerweile angedacht oder auch schon in politische Beschlüsse umgesetzt wurde, dass man die vorhandenen Materialien, die es gibt zur Chemie, zur Tiermedizin, zur Theologie, ob das YouTube-Videos sind oder Webseiten, dass man die qualitätssichert und den Hochschulen in Deutschland anbietet, als Materialien, die sie in der eigenen Lehre verwenden können. Also da gibt es ganz viel und es gibt Hochschulen, die machen das auch, die haben ganz explizit auf ihren Webseiten Videos, die aus anderen, leider nie aus Deutschland, aber immer aus anderen Ländern kommen, die sie dann ihren Studierenden empfehlen.
Es gibt da auch sehr viel Widerstand aus so Schulbuchverlagen etc. Lehrmittelbereichen, die ja und das hatten wir ja noch bis vor kurzem, hatten wir harte Debatten im Kontext von Urheberrechtsgesetzen, da wurden ja Lehrer sozusagen schon in juristische Bredouille gebracht, wenn sie nur angefangen haben, Seiten zu kopieren, um die mal rauszugeben, da reden wir noch gar nicht von online überhaupt. Was ein bisschen absurd wirkt.
Aber wenn wir jetzt über die Urheberrechtsfrage sprechen, dann brauchen wir noch eine Stunde glaube ich.
Ja aber ist ja kein unwichtiger Aspekt. Ich meine nicht, dass wir das jetzt gelöst bekommen. Aber am Ende ist ja auch, wo ein Wille ist, ist auch ein Weg. Die Frage ist, wo ist der Wille. Und da muss ja auch erst mal die Einsicht stehen, dass jetzt sozusagen auch am Ende – da sind wir wieder beim Mehrwert – Mehrwert sowohl für das Bildungssystem, Mehrwert natürlich vor allem für die Ausbildung als solche und damit eben für die Studenten. Wenn ich es richtig rauslese, Sie plädieren im Prinzip für mehr oder die komplette Digitalisierung aller Lehrmittel?
Ja.
Und im Idealfall eben auch einer Interaktivisierung der Lehrpläne?
Ja. Also mein Credo ist, dass die Hochschulen – die Digitalisierung aller möglichen Lehrszenarien und Lehrmaterialien kommt. Entweder ist sie schon da in einigen Fächern oder sie kommt in absehbarer naher oder ferner Zukunft und die Frage ist dann, braucht man dann überhaupt noch Hochschulen und Lehrende? Und ich meine, ja, man braucht sie, wenn man kluge Präsenzphasenkonzepte bereithält. Und damit müssen die Hochschulen punkten, mit ihren Präsenzszenarien. Die können nicht mit ihren digitalen Szenarien punkten, dazu brauchen sie keine Hörsäle mehr. Aber mit klugen Präsenzphasen, mit top Lehrenden, zu denen man gern hingeht. Das kann ein Mediziner sein, der eine Show abliefert a la Dr. House. Das kann ein Harald Lesch sein, der toll im ZDF seine Dinge vorträgt. Solche Lehrende braucht man. Die begeistern und die in ihren Präsenzphasen die Studenten mitreißen. Und das können eben nur diese 20%. Viele werden das einfach nicht erreichen.
Die müssen nicht arbeitslos werden, aber die sollen dann eben mehr in die Forschung hineingehen und andere eben mehr in die Lehre. ich glaube, es wird so kommen müssen. Also man spricht immer von Lehr- und Forschungsprofessur. Ich bin nicht für eine Trennung, aber es wird in die Richtungen mehr gehen.
Spezialisierung unter Umständen sinnvoll. Was ja nicht heißt, dass jemand der forscht, nicht auch der Lehre was beitragen kann und umgekehrt.
Er muss ja auch vortragen können seine Forschungsergebnisse. Das heißt er kann vielleicht von den guten Lehrenden auch profitieren, indem er bei ihnen in die Lehre geht, wie man gut vorträgt. Und genauso können die Lehrenden, die top Forscher in ihre Lehre integrieren.
Vor allem für die inhaltliche Ausprägung.
Ja genau.
Ist das noch aktuell? Wo sollten wir da noch hinmarschieren? Was müssen wir noch beachten.
Es darf aber nicht so ein, dass es eine 2-Klassen-Gesellschaft wird und es heißt, nur die Forscher zählen was und die Lehrenden nicht. Also insofern, das ist glaube ich die Zukunft der Hochschule, dass diese Präsenzphase, das ist das Herz. Es sei denn man entschließt sich wie in Hamburg zu einer Open-Online-University. Kann es auch geben so etwas. Also die Onlinelehre wird eine große Rolle spielen, gar keine Frage.
Die Fortsetzung der Idee der Fernuniversität, die einfach für manche Leute, die diese Präsenz nicht leisten können, einfach aus anderen Gründen.
Ja oder auch, wir bieten ja auch unseren Studierenden, das ist ein einzigartiges Angebot in Deutschland, Onlinelehre im Curriculum an, und zwar für den Fall der Schwangerschaft, Krankheit, Auslandsaufenthalt und Stundenplankollision. Da dürfen unsere Studierenden völlig ohne Präsenz die Kurse online machen und kriegen spezielle Onlinematerialien dann geboten. Ich glaube, das gibt es sonst nirgendwo. Die sitzen im gleichen Kurs wie ihre Kommilitoninnen und Kommilitonen, die das mit Präsenz machen. Nur sie haben eine spezielle Genehmigung zur Onlineabsolvierung durch diese vier Verhinderungsgründe, die ich genannt habe.
Was dann auch noch mal ein ganz anderer Grad an Inklusion ist.
Auch das ja. Bestimmt. Also das ist der eine Punkt, Open Education Ressources und all die Konsequenzen. Und der andere Punkt, den man in diesem Zusammenhang ansprechen kann ist, dass die Politik sich möglicherweise mehr um den Mittelbau kümmert. Denn es ist ja letztlich so, wenn man überlegt, die Digitalisierung der Lehre muss ja gemacht werden. Es müssen Webseiten erstellt werden, es müssen Videos erzeugt werden, es müssen Audiodateien gemacht werden und geschnitten werden und harmonisiert werden mit Präsentationen. Die Präsentationen müssen erstellt werden und da reicht es nicht, wenn man nur PowerPoint kennt. Da muss viel mehr her. Da sind interaktive Grafikpakete werden da eingesetzt. Die Frage ist, muss das ein Hochschullehrer machen? Ich habe gesagt, zum Teil ja, aber alles kann er oder sie ja auch nicht schaffen. Also braucht man Mitarbeiter. Und die Mitarbeiter in deutschen Hochschulen sind maximal auf 6 Jahre im eigenen Team zu halten.
Es sei denn, man hat Drittmittel, dann kann man noch weitergehen, aber irgendwann wird die Hochschule sagen, jetzt ist Schluss, weil wir das Teilzeitgesetz haben und die Mitarbeiter dann nicht mehr weiter beschäftigt werden können. Und hinzukommt, dass es ja keine Drittmittel für die Lehre gibt. Es gibt immer nur Forschungsmittel. Und Drittmittel für die Lehre, wenn man sie hat, dann werden das meistens kurzfristige Sachen, die über ein Jahr an Landespakete gekoppelt werden, die ihren Haushalt immer nur ein Jahr behandeln können. Und dann muss man Ausschreibungen machen, eine halbe Mitarbeiterstelle für ein Jahr. Wer möchte eine solche Stelle gern bekleiden? Ich habe solche Mitarbeiterinnen und Mitarbeiter, die machen das. Ich bewundere sie, dass sie das tun.
Aber auch weil sie letzten Endes auf eine längerfristige Beschäftigung an der Universität hoffen und sie diese Verbindungen nicht haben. Nicht weil sie jetzt diese Situation an sich toll finden.
Also ich bin kein Haushaltsexperte, wie das Landeshaushalte zum Beispiel lösen könnten, aber hier muss man mal drüber nachdenken. Gerade in diesem Bereich braucht man eine größere Nachhaltigkeit als im klassischen Mitarbeiterbereich, in der Politologie oder sonst wo
Ja weil sich ja hier im Prinzip auch Karrieren abspielen müssen und Leute eine Perspektive haben, damit sie da auch motiviert reingehen und eine entsprechend gute Arbeit leisten und jetzt nicht nur so nach Vorschrift, wie es gerade so passt macht, weil gerade der Bereich Medienproduktion, haben wir ja schon angesprochen, Sie haben jetzt hier sehr viel alleine entwickelt und aus eigenem Antrieb und eigener Begeisterung heraus gemacht, das mag ja nun nicht unbedingt immer so gelagert sein bei jedem, das kann man ja verstehen.
Muss ja auch nicht.
Aber in dem Moment, wo man den Leuten halt kompetente Mitarbeiter mitgibt, die in ihrer Tätigkeit dann auch eine Perspektive sehen und sagen, okay wir bauen jetzt hier für die Universität ein universelles Medienproduktionszentrum auf, wir schaffen hier ein Studio, wir kümmern uns um die Kameratechnik, was ja dann ganz nebenbei auch noch den Vorteil hat, dass das ja dann im Prinzip von allen auch genutzt werden kann, ganz andere Ökonomisierung hat. Abgesehen, der Kreideverbrauch sinkt ja auch laufend.
Das ist wichtig ja.
Das wollen wir ja auch nicht rauslassen.
Staubentwicklung.
Feinstaubproblematik wird gelöst. Also ich verstehe was Sie sagen. Also man müsste an der Stelle einfach auch die gesamte personelle Aufstellung neu denken.
Ja.
Ja Herr Hanke, das war jetzt mal ein sehr aufschlussreiches Gespräch. Ich bedanke mich sehr.
Danke Ihnen Herr Pritlove.
Und ja ich bedanke mich wie immer auch bei allen, die hier zugehört haben. Und wir tauchen auch in den nächsten Sendungen sicherlich noch sehr viel mehr in Themen der Lehre und Digitalisierung mit ein. Aber für den heutigen Tag war es das erst mal bis dann. Tschüss und bis bald.